i'd like to call the
committee hearing to order on house bill
1316 direct uh
directing the director of the state
police
to develop the requirements for e-foil
and electric hydrofoil surfboard
watercraft
and the chair calls the
prime sponsor
suzanne gottling
for five minutes for five minutes
maybe more or less
considering i have 45 minutes for this
we should be
um
oh
thank you you need one for the uh
for the clerk
yeah problem actually probably i don't
know if it's probably
yeah before the clerk may need a second
yep that's good
uh can you hear me
okay thank you yes again
uh thank you mr chairman and good
morning to all the committee members
i'm here this morning to introduce hb
1316.
that established that asked new
hampshire to establish safety
requirements for e-foil
and electric hydrofoil surfboard
watercraft which are probably the same
thing but
my attention was drawn to this method of
propulsion
last summer when an apparition went by
my front window
an apparently airborne human
traveling as fast as a motorboat while
standing on a small board two or three
feet above the water
this caught my attention
conversations with our local police
chief and with captain dunn levy
provided some background on this rapidly
emerging water sport and hours on the
internet furthered my education
and e-foil as you have the diagram in
front of you
consists of anywhere from a four foot
four inch to six foot two inch board
attached to a three foot mast picture an
upside down sailboat
at the bottom of which is a propeller
and a hydrofoil it is powered by a
lithium-ion battery
and controlled by a hand-held bluetooth
throttle that turns power off if the
throttle hits the water
or the border exceeds a 45 degree tilt
the e-foil rises out of the water by
delicate adjustments to the balance of
the rider
and e-foil can travel
25 to 30 miles an hour its battery lasts
from 90 to 120 minutes
it is quiet and it makes no wake
efoils were developed about six years
ago in puerto rico and australia
as of september 2020
according to a new york times article
there were about 300 dealers worldwide
that number has undoubtedly increased
since then
bloomberg businessweek in a may 2021
article called it an emerging sport for
the wealthy
there are several e-foil blogs that
share e-foil highs
flying over the water going straight
ahead or carving expert turns and the
lows
days of pain from trigger figure
trigger finger impairments or pitching
head first into the drink when you hit a
fish or submerged log
how widespread is e-foily in new
hampshire
our state is already home
to several sales and lesson outlets and
a laconia company hydrocomp inc
designed the propeller
in sunapee last summer there were
several complaints lodged against
e-foilers
weaving their way or falling off the
board into crowd into our crowded harbor
frequent lessons took place in one of
our narrowest coves
the letter from the new hampshire lakes
advisory committee
further indicates e-foiling is alive and
well and growing in new hampshire
new hampshire presently classifies the
e-foil as a boat
and as you know boats with motors are
required to follow many regulations
designed to keep the boater safe
a boater must have registration decals
in the proper place for identification
carry on board his or her registration
and voting certificate
as well as a life jacket paddle
signaling device and lights for
traveling at night
how many of these requirements are
followed by e-foilers
what is the appropriate penalty for
failing to follow voting rules
should any rules or requirements or
penalties be adapted or modified
other countries and states have been
wrestling with these questions
australia prohibits efoils from sydney
harbor
and my police chief would applaud
similar action for sunapee harbor
with its two large tour boats shoreside
restaurant with docking space and
thousands of off-lake boats launching
throughout the season
california wrestles with the difficulty
of tracking the weightless noiseless
e-foil in diminished light conditions
the lake george commission allows
operation only in daylight hours
many
require the life jacket to be worn as
there is no attention attachment of the
rider to the board
i am sure captain dunleavy can think of
other issues
to examine such as can two riders occupy
one board or can an e-foil be used for
towing
this is my effort to help the committee
understand
why hb 1316 is needed
e-foiling as described by advocates
is of course
the best thing to hit the deck since
dare i say it wake boats
one enthusiast writes that he traded in
his hundred and twenty thousand dollar
wake boat for twelve thousand dollar
efoil
one tenth the price
more fun
and better for the environment
i believe we failed to appreciate the
potential impacts of wake surfing until
too many new hampshire residents had
bought a wake boat with a mortgage as
you remember on our field trip
comparable to a home mortgage
help new hampshire stay ahead of the
game
by looking now into the role efoils
should play on our new hampshire waters
thank you are there any questions by
members of the committee
representative gould and representative
smith
whatever your question is uh
well
i'll answer if i can okay uh one of them
is how slow can it go
how what how slow
oh
you mean and still maintain headway
speed
uh
probably
you know i honestly i don't know that
okay but you have to get a certain
amount of speed too
you know what
when you start off on on it you're lying
on your stomach
and you can make it go as fast as you
want that way but to get up on it you
there it's a very delicate uh
enterprise that you don't bring the
board way up and get flipped over
backwards or that you don't adjust it so
that you can rise out of the water
we have someone here who hasn't ridden
one so
for a follow-up
thank you mr chairman
and how deep is the uh the thing that
goes into the water
pardon me how how deep is the thing that
goes into the water it's a three feet
a pattern three feet
okay yeah so when they rise up as you
can see in that one photo they're really
quite high
above the water
thank you
representative smith
for questions
thank you mr chair for taking my
question
and thank you representative for taking
it um
have you seen these in your neighborhood
on lake sunapee representative gottling
yep i have that's got my attention
yes thank you and and i've talked to the
we we had a number of incidents with
them in addition yeah
so
anyone else will get any other questions
from the
from the committee
scene
representative post for a question
excuse me for a second uh representative
gould can you shut your mic thanks thank
you
representative thank you mr chair and um
thank you today for presenting this
i i just have a question about the
police making the rules would that not
be like marine patrol yes but but marine
patrol comes under the authority of
department of safety okay thank you very
much
any other questions from members of the
committee
being done thank you very much thank you
you can take your seat back here just
obviously you know the rules as far as
yep that that's right
but
in the interest of
safety
all right if if you wish
but you can come here especially if we
are more crowded that if best to be up
here simply because
of you know the covet issue
chair calls uh representative uh
duchesne
for three minutes
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
to the committee for letting me testify
i'm one of the co-sponsors of house bill
1316 which uh seeks to
create a rules-making process for what
representative gottling aptly described
as a delicate enterprise i really like
that description of it but um so the
purpose of this legislation is to
address the increasing use of e-foil
electric hydrofoil surfboard watercraft
on new hampshire's fresh bodies of water
as a resident of wolfeboro and their
state representative i've seen firsthand
how several new technologies are
revolutionizing personal watercraft
boats recreational activities on our
lakes here in the granite state this
development is great for tourism
throughout new hampshire and tracks many
new seasonal vacationers and new
homeowners however there are some
drawbacks and stresses on our resources
caused by what can sometimes be an
uncontrollable increase um the increase
in efoils and electrochiral surfboards
has created more traffic on lake
winnipesaukee specifically i can speak
from uh from
from
from experience boating in the varney
islands in the alton bay area south
wolfeboro bay wolfeboro bay winter
harbor
by cow island 19 mile 20 mile bay and
melvin village
and moultonborough bay
i would say you know these new personal
watercraft are not people who use these
e-foils are not necessarily trained or
educated on boating laws or standard
practices for navigating the lake this
means careless use of e-foils and
electrochiral surfboards can pose a
hazard to boaters and it's quite often
you have folks without life vests
without any kind of real experience
maybe they've had you know a few drinks
because it might be younger they might
be more you know aggressive using these
resources and everything and they will
you know tend to get in the way of
regular traffic they'll tend to you know
get close to people's shoreline um
unusually close than what's typical for
a kind of watercraft they'll travel 25
to 30 miles an hour um a good analogy i
like to use is it's like long border
skateboarders or cyclists using the
roads without any understanding of
traffic safety laws right there would be
increased accidents that's essentially
what these kinds of uh these e-foils and
hydrofoils that we're kind of
introducing and imagine if none of them
have helmets right so that's kind of
what we have as an issue now the lake is
different because it's not a narrow
strip of area that everyone must share
right roads are pretty constricted but
it's also pretty obvious where you go on
the road if you're a pedestrian or
someone who's essentially not an
automobile it's operating like a bicycle
with the lake it's more open and you can
travel in unlimited directions though
right there is no restriction but that
also means that lakes can be much more
chaotic to traverse especially with less
experienced boaters on busy weekends
adding e-foils and electric hydrofoil
surfboards so this mix mainly when
operated by less experienced users makes
complex for even makes makes complex
travel even more difficult especially
for people who are renting boats that
could be you know first-time boat users
that's a very common thing i mean lake
winnipesaukee is starting to see record
number of people renting votes from out
of state coming in state and utilizing
our resources this is a great thing for
my local economy but it's also somewhat
of a risk right and put stresses on a
number of emergency response
in different communities like mine
as you all know the state of new
hampshire holds and trusts the public
waters including all natural lakes and
and ponds of 10 acres or more in size
navigable rivers and tidal waters for
the use and benefit for the people of
states so our job as state legislators
as trustees of this public trust is to
responsibly regulate these resources so
everyone can safely and effectively use
them this legislation strikes a balance
between over stringent regulations and
creating some basic safety and
standardized practices like we do for
all personal watercraft on our fresh
waters in the state of state of new
hampshire
this affirmation responsibility is
significantly important to my
constituency of wolfeboro residents
business owners and tourists expect to
utilize a myriad of fun watercraft but
want some security while using these
watercraft right whether it's other
watercraft they're using that aren't
e-foils that are traversing these lakes
or the e-foils and themselves right or
people who rent who are first-time users
that don't really understand what the
kind of best practices are right
um it also drives our local economy
which depends on tourism but you know
there's a balance that needs to be
struck right without that certain amount
of safety and people coming back after
having a good time um you know people
won't want to come back they'll go to
other places um so i encourage the
community to vote ought to pass on house
bill 1316 i was also be happy to work
with any committee member to make
changes to the legislation if necessary
and
remain open to any questions uh thank
you
any questions by members of the
committee representative huff
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
representative for taking my question
um you mentioned
that personal watercraft on the lake you
know like cedars i used to have a sea
doo um
i already have uh rules in place why not
just apply those rules to this
well because um part of the reason is
what the legend to my understanding the
legislation would allow for that process
to happen right we need to direct the
state police who controls marine patrol
to direct them to make rules unless the
legislature directs these agencies to
make rules and they're i don't think
they can just go off and women decide
how to define these and to make the
rules for them so this is just enabling
them to do that process to work with the
public and to create some you know
basically some standardized best
practices for how these are going to be
used on a public resource great
thank you
any other questions i'm members of the
committee
representative
mayfield and uh represent representative
gould
mayfield
sorry
you got to turn your thing toward me
no the uh your
your uh yeah your
amigo thank you mr chair for taking my
question thank you representative i'm
sorry i misunderstood i thought i heard
in the original speaker that um these
efoils were defined as boats and would
therefore follow the same
restrictions as boats was i
incorrect in my hearing
um to my understanding um i i don't know
where exactly they're defining the law
but i know they're not under the same
requirements as boats right so you don't
have to wear a life preserver you don't
have to have
these kinds of um these e-foils
registered right you don't need to get a
perimeter a sticker or anything for the
most part you just buy it you can just
use it on the resource
so i don't maybe i'm mistaken and
yeah captain dunleavy can kind of um can
kind of but to my understanding this is
just requiring the department of state
police to adopt some basic rules and to
enable them to be able to do that
your question answered
you okay thank you uh representative
gould okay thank you mr chair and thank
you representative uh just a question
once again about the item itself uh can
it go on a river or up a little stream
yeah it could go up for the most part it
can go anywhere where you know you can
be able to get um probably i mean you
would probably need at least i'd say
that's obviously you got three you got
three feet of the foil itself right and
um so you need that to be able to um i'm
trying to the draft right so you need at
least like three to four feet of draft
but anything with three or four feet of
draft with probably about you know six
feet to be able to move around and yeah
you could probably go up a stream down a
river um you could traverse tidal waves
and everything out in the ocean you can
go lake winnipesaukee you can go into
back bay lay in your stomach and go
under the bridge there and then go into
back bay in wolfeboro you go all over
the place i mean basically if you've got
four feet of water this this thing's
going to take you there okay thank you
any other questions and
seeing none
thank you very much thank you for having
me
and now we'll
now we'll get to the person who has all
the answers and all the questions
captain dunlevy the marine patrol thank
you very much
you mr chairman honorable members of the
committee my name is tim dunleavy
captain of the marine patrol unit for
the division of state police
and i come before you this morning not
only to answer any of your questions
but to offer the support of this bill on
behalf of the department
i think it is important to point out
that this statute or this this bill is
is going to
create the statute in statute the
ability of the commissioner only to
develop rulemaking for these craft
which if you're not familiar obviously
that that whole process involves public
input so
it's recognizing this craft in the
marine environment making it eligible
for rulemaking
we had a temporary designation from the
coast guard
about a year ago
uh acknowledging the existence of these
uh devices they are definitely in their
infancy in the overall scheme of the
boating world
uh we are anticipating uh any week now
the official designation of these craft
as boats uh
at the
level of the federal government and our
existing rules already
would uh recognize once it is designated
a boat
things like certain safety equipment
life jacket wear
what may come of this though is the
requirement to wear it
devices similar to this on the water
like a personal watercraft
perhaps a person on a wake board being
towed skiers
whenever there's a separation from the
person
from whatever it is they're riding
obviously there's then a lack of
floatation particularly if the person's
injured so that's something that a
legislature may want to look at is to
whether or not a mandatory wear of life
jackets while using this type of a
device is appropriate that's going to be
separate from the rule-making authority
that we're talking about
so i'm happy to answer any of your
questions
but department of safety does offer the
support for this bill
any questions represent represent
representative post then representative
smith you mr chair and i think you have
yours on
thank you um and and thank you um
captain dunleavy for being here today so
my question is if it's
um going to be designated as a boat and
i'm you're pretty sure that's going to
happen right
um
will there be the same things where if
someone was renting a boat
on a lake um that you have to get a
temporary
license to do that would that be part of
this
and also
a watercraft a personal watercraft would
it
fall more under that than the personal
watercraft so those are my two questions
thank you
thank you for your questions first off
once we receive the designation that it
is considered a vessel we will have to
do an analysis as to whether or not the
propulsion is equivalent to a certain
horsepower
um
we then look at whether or not that
horsepower is generated at the engine or
in this case the machine the battery
system
or at the propeller whenever you're
dealing with electric here you're losing
significant horsepower by the time that
energy gets to the propeller
absent all those physics the current
statute set by you folks says that
anybody operating a vessel greater than
25 horsepower needs that education
requirement
while this vessel will achieve certain
speeds similar to other boats the actual
horsepower of the craft may not initiate
that education requirement so we're
going to have to do that analysis once
it's designated as a as a vessel
as far as designating it a personal
watercraft
it it is
somewhat outside of the existing
definition of personal watercraft set by
you folks
and in addition
i would be
cautious to folks to look at what
currently exists in statute for
restrictions applied to ski craft
this is a fairly low impact
craft
once it's designated a boat it's going
to need to be 150 feet away from
shorelines and docks when it operates
it's going to need to be at headway
speed
at certain places and times which is all
controlled by this handheld device
they're not going to be up and out of
the water at headway speed the person's
going to have to be lying on it
and so it's going to be drawing three
and a half four feet with a person's
body weight so it's going to be
restricted as to where it can go
environmentally just due to the nature
of the propulsion system
so
um
to engage it or or to throw it in the
same
uh category as personal watercraft or
ski craft
there may be some restrictions there
that already exist that the legislature
may no one have applied to this craft
so it would be something to look at
keep in mind the some of those early
restrictions were due to noise um
how close to shore they were
quick movements and some of that noise
this is
this is a very quiet craft so those are
some of the things that that you folks
would need to look at in the future
okay so of cut through
oh you're fun can i do a follow-up uh
just just i i have i would like a
question just as a clarification so
you are
really talking about
future statute
statutes coming before this committee
specific to this
device
only to the extent that that
the users of the lake or you folks as a
legislature would want to further
restrict them beyond that of a
traditional boat okay
for a follow-up
okay
rep representative smith for a question
yeah thank you captain dunleavy um
so and i'm i'm actually probably asking
for the same clarification uh that the
chair did which
is you're saying with the rules that you
would be developing under this bill
that you would not be able to require
the wearing of life jackets that would
have to be done by legislation
thank you for your question yes the that
is falls outside of the scope of the
commissioner's authority for rulemaking
on vessels
uh so mandatory wearing of life jacket
would need to be uh in a statute
follow-up
and um one of my concerns uh with this
and with probably any vessel on the
water
is uh the aquatic invasive species um
the co-sponsored representative de shays
talked about people using them in back
bay and i know back bay is kind of full
of
milfoil and other aquatic invasives and
when we're talking about something that
goes down four feet
we're talking about stirring up ais
moving them around and i wondered if
rules would be designating
the depth of water that they could be in
or i don't i don't know how you would do
that but is that possible
that would be very difficult to to
establish in rule making just because
um
to designate a zone of a certain depth
um is very difficult from the person at
the surface never mind from the officer
and from an enforcement perspective um
but certainly i recognize your your
concern where the depth of the
propulsion is low in the water
at slow speeds
once the person
by the way you need a lot of
coordination and practice with this
before you're going to be
uh fairly comfortable on it and use it
to its full potential which means you're
going to be up and out of the water off
the surface and only that propulsion
will be below the surface which at that
point it's quite high in the water
but at slow speeds just starting off
that's when that propulsion system is
going to be amongst the weeds in shallow
water that's true
rulemaking would not be able to address
that specifically for an aquatic aquatic
invasive concern
um because it would the only way it
could do that is to to restrict it from
certain areas
uh so and that's a i've been there
okay thank you very much thank you
any other questions from from members of
the committee representative harp for a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question captain um do you
have any idea how many of these we have
in new hampshire
thank you for the question
we have
one rental operation that actually gives
lessons they're a dealer as well as a
rental
there are a couple of other satellite
dealers that's really in its infancy i
would say
at the most we may have
100 to 150
right now
but they are about to
to get even more popular
and i i will say right now we are not
receiving an overwhelming number of
phone calls of concern
some of the concerns are from people on
shore saying hey where's their life
jacket
but i will i will say that the
the operations that we have seen so far
have been very responsible
it's a machine that
sort of like water skiing
wake surfing wake boarding
it's almost as if the people who are
using them
already think the water is in place that
they need to wear to life check it
because it makes sense to so we're not
seeing a lot of problems out there
one or two here or there where someone
isn't wearing a jacket but for the most
part people think they're supposed to be
anyway so we're not seeing a whole lot
of problems at this point
any other questions from members of the
committee representative post for a
first second question
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
dunleavy again um so with these wake
boards uh do they have a similar system
well they're not weak boards
they're e-foils but um on unlike
personal watercraft there's something
you can put around your arm and that
will pull the key out in an emergency is
there does this just stop
thank you
thank you for your question the unique
thing with this craft is everything is
controlled by a wrist worn device so um
once the signal is is lost through
bluetooth
it automatically stops and so that
safety uh backup is there but also the
the user is able to control it its speed
of the the speed of the prop
from its wrist so once there's
separation they still have control to a
certain distance once the signal is lost
then it stops
i will add that the ruling
with safety equipment like tethers life
jackets fire extinguishers whistles
those types of things this craft is
going to be unique and that there's not
a lot of places to store a life jacket
where once the designation comes that
it's a boat and the carriage requirement
for a jacket to be on board
for all the users there's no place to
put it so
if the jacket needs to be there the only
other place to have it is on you so
somewhat by default i think we're going
to see lifejacket where
representative huff for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you captain
um
this is interesting
i don't want to get into a commercial
for e-foils
but just out of curiosity when i had my
sea doo and i would bring it you know
through the weir's channel or or in
various spots that even pagas bay
it can be brutal out there i mean
serious hard waves how does this thing
go in in that kind of a chop because i
know with my sidoo it was much more fun
you know if you're going to just be
going on a less chop of a surface and it
was not nearly as life-threatening
so is it the same with this or
in the beginning yes because you can't
start
out on this device in an upright
position with the board out of the water
so while the board is in the water and
while that rider is getting the
coordination and bringing it up to speed
so that the foil itself starts to lift
you
you are going to be subject to that chop
that wave
and in an awake zone you're going to
have to be lying on the board because
you can't by law exceed six miles an
hour
interestingly once you are up and out of
the water
it's just this very narrow shaft that's
that's plowing through these waves so
you're not feeling the effect of the
chalk
if you fall down you are now beneath
you know you're in the you're not on the
peak of the height of that wave you're
in the trough and so
there's going to be some
some effort to get through that chop to
get back to that elevated position
thank you
representative post for a third question
yes um again thank you mr chair and
thank you captain don levy so in in
looking at this if someone falls off of
it
and there's a lot of chop is that
vessel just floating out
without any way to recover it
it would be a short distance away from
the user uh and so there is going to
need to be some effort on behalf of the
user to get back to the to the machine
certainly
any other questions from members of the
committee
actually i have one one question just
occurred to me
now right now i understand there's
not
tandem boards available
but will there be
or can there be
uh it wouldn't surprise me
representative over time
certainly uh the developments in
machines like this
uh are developed to meet the appeal of
the users and certainly we've seen
certain devices in the past it started
off as as being a device for one user
that have expanded
to many more
obviously the advancement of the
electric technology
uh and the amount of power that the
device will offer to support two people
is probably happening faster than we all
can imagine
but that's my speculation
thank you
any other
questions for members of the committee
if not thank you very much
thank you very much
seeing seeing no other having no other
pink cards
and seeing no one
looking to pass one along
i'll declare the
meeting the hearing closed on 13 16.
and the next one will be in five minutes
which is 13 17.
moving right moving right along
you
all right
uh
we'll call the meeting to order for the
hearing to order for
house bill 13 1317
requiring the director of the state
police
in consultation with the bureau of
marine patrol to report annually to the
legislature
regarding new developments in electric
and gasoline-powered recreational
watercraft
representative gottling you have the
chair
you have the four rather i have the
yeah i'm going to have a rest after this
morning
thank you again mr chairman and
committee members
hb 1317
is a bill intended to keep the resource
committees of both the house and senate
aware of emerging electric or
gasoline-powered boating technology
that may present challenges
to standing rules and
sorry about that
it will encourage legislators to address
in timely fashion
potential safety or environmental
impacts on new hampshire water bodies as
well as possible conflicts with uses
already taking place
you have heard from me about the swift
and growing appearance of efoils on our
lakes and rivers
three years ago i brought attention to
the unknown environmental effects of
wake boats
i have no doubt
that there will be more issues in the
future from the products
of the ingeniously inventive
have i mentioned yet propelled motorized
surfboards
the intention of this bill is that the
department of safety through marine
patrol
share with the appropriate legislative
committees
knowledge gained through its access to
reports from patrol officers of unique
activity
through complaints received throughout
the state and through awareness gained
from national conferences or educational
events
it may be that a report is one sentence
or several pages its intention is to
give legislators a heads up and a head
start
and i would also say that
marine patrol is uh neutral on this bill
i ask for your support to this
forward-looking bill
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i'm just curious um this bill
as opposed to the previous bill why is
there a difference in referencing marine
patrol specifically in this bill
and not the previous uh the intention
would be the same and uh it would be
the uh
whatever came to me out of ols and i did
not pick up those differences thank you
so much
be happy to amend
representative representative post for a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you i just
wonder
would this not happen under normal
reporting
uh i didn't have anybody contact me
about efoils
so
you know
no
that that was
something that i saw happening and went
ahead with it
so i i don't think that we have a
mechanism by which
marine patrol
uh
regularly reports the kind of thing i'm
asking for
in this bill
for a follow-up
um so
if it's going to be regulated by the
federal government and that it's going
to now be identified as a vessel
would that not
make it happen
that they would report these kind of
things
uh they might report they might report
it to their patrol officers and other
folks with enforcement uh but they're
not necessarily going to report it to
legislators for something that needs to
be done
or a follow-up so do we get any
information on any other vessels that
normally happens like that
i would refer
i have not
thank you perhaps captain donnelly can
answer that
i i don't think we had any information
about wake votes and potentials that
came from
really a lot of the protective
associations throughout the state
is where the awareness of that came from
and that's why i didn't include it
in here because i feel as if the
protective associations pay attention to
the cyanobacter
bacteria and they pay attention to the
milfoil and aquatic invasives
and secondarily perhaps they would look
at these emergency technologies but i
feel as if
well i felt as if
captain dunleavy gave us
two instances of where we are going to
need to think about legislation
and hopefully
uh and you know and that would probably
be done in the next session but who's
going to remember it you know we
so
if that was sent
either to members to the chairperson or
members of the committee
uh then somebody could say do i want to
deal with that or not
it's really just giving an
opportunity
uh
to share in a more uh concrete
manner
uh what they what they know and i know
they have uh a bit of that captain
dunleavy goes to a national conference
and that uh he foils were under a lot of
discussion at that
so that was helpful to know that
and my guess is you know i i spent a lot
of time trying to imagine well what's
going to be the next thing
and i would encourage any of you who can
think of something let me know
we might make a fortune if we can
produce it
that answer your ques feel me that
answer your question
representative creighton for a question
thank you mr chairman representative
in your estimation what
what is the scope of this report i mean
is this a one page is it an email or is
it a 500 page dissertation well i
certainly hope it's not 500 pages and i
think it would would be i i would think
there might be a time when we've done
such a brilliant job and people are you
know so on top of things that it would
be we have nothing to report
uh
the the one uh
but i i would think it could be a
summary of uh
what they see might be coming down the
path the pike particularly from uh when
they get uh at this national conference
or things like that
yeah okay thank you ma'am
but no i don't want 500 pages thank you
is there any other questions
from members of the committee
thank you very much thank you
i have no other questions uh or no other
pink cards
uh
the
represent representative harp for
question or uh observation
i have a combination of the both i
thought maybe captain donnelly was going
to come and say something i have a
question for captain don livery if we
can ask him to come forward
kevin dunleavy do you yield
uh tim delavey department of safety
marine patrol and i'm here for any
questions you may have
thank you captain for taking my question
it was brought up and my concern is to
mandate something that maybe the
director's already doing does the
director normally create an annual
report that's available to anyone that
can simply be
sent to the committee without having to
pass a statute
thank you for your question
representative the department of safety
does produce an annual report
that document speaks mainly and we are
included in that that document speaks
mainly to what what we have done
statistics uh what what the the agency
has produced over the last uh fiscal
year
this type of report
the legislature may consider four
reasons that representative gottling
specifically mentioned
like weight boats but i i won't just
i'll i'll throw out a couple of others
where
the legislature ultimately has seen
an urgent need to somehow regulate in
the in the late 80s it was the original
jet skis
now there's a lot of talk about wake
surfing
there are controversial activities that
hit our waters where
the competing uses of the public
uh
are coming to your attention uh by your
constituencies
um
marine patrol in the department of
safety has historically absent
a safety issue
has historically stayed away from
environmental conflicts user conflicts
and allowing the boating public to
decide whether it be through the
legislative process for the hearings
process on the administrative rules side
as to how they want to be regulated in
that activity
and and sometimes the the issue uh
becomes so large so quickly that you
folks are blindsided by it and i can
only uh guess that that's representative
gotling's intent here
us filing a report might be similar to
what some of the ongoing legislative uh
created committees like lakes management
advisory aquatic invasive species
committees that there are a multitude of
them there are none out there that
specifically address voting
so um
whether this report whether it be one
page two pages just to say hey this is
coming or this is what we're seeing for
trends we leave it up to you as to
whether you want to hear about that or
not
thank you captain
representative smith for a question
thank you captain dunleavy um yes and um
as chair of the aquatic invasive weeds
and species committee
um amy smagula who is our
finger on the pulse person for the
state
what's happening in the invasives world
does report to us at meetings it's very
casual it's in the course of her monthly
report
and so i think that and it doesn't
require us to do anything but it gives
us the heads up that water chestnut was
found here this one's coming from
another state and i think something like
that could be very helpful um for us
just to know you know if when you're at
your annual meetings your national
meetings that
what's happening in colorado could be
happening here in a year or two and just
kind of give us the heads up i think
that would be good is that a reasonable
request and the question is
it doesn't look like that this bill is
requiring a formal
review report kind of a thing it doesn't
looks look to be
unbearably
challenging to complete is that correct
in your opinion
based of one i've seen what i've read uh
i i don't anticipate it being a heavy
lift if i can use that expression okay
thank you
representative post for a question
thank you very much chair and thank you
mr uh captain dunleavy um
again i i wonder do we really need a
bill
to have you report on this for us
and it could it just be in the normal
course of reporting
uh with all due respect i would say
that's up to you folks uh i i don't know
what
what um would be required of us if this
if there wasn't this bill
uh if there's just a simple request by
the committee to come and before you and
give you updates i i don't know what
mechanisms exist to do that i know we
routinely
share opportunities with boat rides for
you folks as a committee in the past and
there's a lot of conversation
which which we as an agency enjoy
um
but but but if that doesn't happen
because of covet or what have you uh
what how we get that information to you
absent your request i guess i'm not sure
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much and
could you put a in a pink card
thank you
seeing no additional
testimony be no additional pink cards
i'll declare the hearing on house bill
1317 closed
next hearing is at 10 30.
let's see
we've got 1.3 million people that keep
us surprised at what's going on
i don't know why we need to do it
we can ask him if he wants to make a
presentation
somebody
your microphone
you
okay
i'd like to call the meeting to order
for
the hearing on
house bill
1438 relative to the use of a mooring by
person other than
the permit holder and
i'd like to recognize
the prime sponsor
representative teroshan
representative the floor is yours
thank you mr chair and uh good morning
members of the uh committee
for the record i'm peter teroshan i
represent rockingham county district 14
which is the towns of atkinson in
plaistow as you heard i'm the prime
sponsor of this legislation
and this is a relatively straightforward
and simple intent here
what this
legislation attempts to do
is to allow
the
permit holder of a mooring and it's
intended to be coastal moorings
of which most of you know we have very
limited
coast here in new hampshire
and the
resource of which
uh moorings are in uh is very limited
it's not uncommon to see waiting lists
that go 20 years plus
so so what this legislation is
attempting to do
is to allow
the permit holder
that
and just let me explain how this works
when you
get a mooring in the state
you pay a fee to the state to use that
location
but you put down the tackle
um which is the chain the block
the hmong ball and so forth
that should that's property that you
have to provide the state gets a fee for
that
so right now for the by and large the
moorings and the coastal zone
are all rented out so the state is
getting
their dollar amount whatever it totals
up to i couldn't tell you the exact
number
but what happens and i've been
approached by several salem boat clubs
in other boaters and i'm a boater myself
and
have familiarity with
the
what goes on with the moorings
it's not uncommon in the summer to see a
quarter to a third of moorings in the
coastal mooring fields go unused at
least for some of the summer
so this bill does not allow the more the
permit holder to
you know
change ownership or change the um
the lease if you want to call it that to
that area to somebody else but what it
does do
it allows them to
let
other boaters use the mooring uh
and it's there's no cost involved so
that you can't charge to use it and the
reason why there's two reasons why this
is important one is that
it's again a limited resource that's
being under utilized
many
people that have moorings they use their
boats and they travel sometimes for a
week or longer up the coast and
day trips and so forth and sail clubs
put together a list of people in their
locations because as many clubs we have
membership up and down the east coast so
if somebody's traveling into the region
and you remember that club you can put
it down i'm going to be gone for two
weeks
from the first to the 15th of august
my moorings available because i'll be
off of it so this allows
people to use those moorings that
otherwise go unused why is that good
because it brings people into new
hampshire that may spend money in the
state in the local towns they may
otherwise go somewhere else in new
report mass
you know up to maine so
again it just to be clear this does not
allow you as the permit holder to
change the ownership of the lease
arrangement that's that's still exactly
the same with the port authority that
controls this
and it doesn't affect the amount of
money that the state
collects
it simply allows that
unused resource to be used
more than it is now
and it has potential economic benefits
to the state and the local towns
and so i hope you support an otp
on
house bill 1438 now i noticed they put
an f in on there and i haven't had any
notification from anybody as to why
there should be a fiscal note on this
bill i i can't see where this would cost
any money at all
and quite frankly if you look at that
page
there's no real information in there to
suggest there should be any cost
so i believe that the the
very little cost of any i don't believe
there would be
with that i'll take any questions that
committee members may have in regard to
this legislation
thank you for your testimony any uh
questions uh representative cohen
followed by representative uh gold
brisbane thank you for taking my
question
um what kind of enforcement would be
happening here if i know it says no
person in the bill shall be charged for
the use of the mooring by any other
person but what if
somebody starts using their mourn like
an ab airbnb so you rent it out by the
day
and it's found out either it's
advertised or something what is the
mechanism for enforcement of not
charging someone
to rent or use your mooring
okay thank you representative for the
question so there isn't a mechanism per
se in this bill
but let me just give you the current law
the current law
um
says you can't let anybody use the
mooring period now if you do and some
people do
and you get caught i don't know what's
in current stature that that has a
punitive amount there may or may not be
something there
so
you know the bottom line is that
this is something that's it's not
intended to
necessarily have a punitive
uh measure but it is intended again to
make that resource usable and the reason
i put in not for hire is because
where there is a waiting list on many of
these
we don't want people to abuse that in in
and lease it out year after year and not
let that mooring go back into the
available pool and that's the reason why
i made it uh not for
no cost involved
thank you for the answer to your quest
my question
representative gould for a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative erosion uh just a quick
question what if somebody knew the
person was away for a month
and uh
just sort of stole the space so to speak
well uh webinar school thank you for the
question
i mean that could happen now i suppose
um as a general rule i i think most
people
work on an honor system that doesn't
mean for a night or two people might
might slip onto a mooring and use it
that does happen
in other states as well
but right now if somebody uses it
whether they have permission or not if
they're violating a current statute and
that's this seeks to
to give some flexibility again and
letting that unused mooring
become valuable for
hopefully potential increased economic
revenue in the state and the local towns
representative connor then
representative huff
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question does marine patrol
currently
actually patrol the moorings to make
sure that the properly licensed person
is using their mooring
thanks for the question representative
i know that in
the inland waterways that that is
something that happens and marine patrol
does patrol the coastal area as well
i guess they could to the extent that
they know who the permit holder is
the port authority which has the
jurisdiction for issuing these moorings
has a list of the permit holders so
they are the ones that would know you
know if they see a different boat
different color different name than what
the permit holder is that perhaps
somebody's using that mooring that's not
the permit holder so
if somebody's out patrolling that
earring doesn't know who the permit
holders are they
probably don't know whether or not
um it's a foreign boat other than if
they're trolling on a regular basis they
get to know what boats look like on
different moorings so they might have an
idea
follow-up
thank you so much do you foresee this
becoming an enforcement issue for either
port authority or marine patrol not
knowing who has permission to be on a
mooring and who does not have permission
no because again um
right now
it's likely many people don't know
exactly who the permit holder is other
than the port authority so i don't see
this causing any problems with increased
enforcement
um and the average person is probably
not going to know
many people don't know what the law is
now and if we change
the statue here
they may not know either but
sale clubs primarily and
both you know voters individually will
get to know and hopefully put
their resource to use
representative huff for question thank
you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
i'm just curious
and this is just a wording uh thing here
where it says um
uh
in line four uh the holder of a mooring
permit may transfer such a permit to a
different person for use up to 30 days
does that mean
and bear with me on this does that mean
only one
person can get that or can multiple
throughout the season get it
can
in other words let me let me back up a
second okay so i'm reading this as a
different person so in other words i own
the mooring you come along and you want
to have it for however long i say okay
and then after you're done using it
that's it there's no other can i get
someone else
do you see what i'm saying yes so so the
way i i interpret the language is that
um
the mooring may be again um transferred
to a different person so meaning a
different person is somebody other than
you as a permit holder okay in for up to
30 days so it doesn't have to be the
same
um
different person
if somebody could use it for
a weekend
and then somewhere
in the 30-day period
you could let somebody else choose it
and again i limit it to 30 days because
i don't want there to be an abuse of
people that
don't have a vessel on the mooring and
they don't turn it back in
um then they could hold them along for
years without having a legitimate
reason to be a permit holder
thank you
representative smith for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
you keep referring to the port authority
and to coastline moorings
um
but
when i look at uh to rsa 270
it
doesn't make a difference it doesn't
seem to differentiate between inland
moorings and coastal moorings
was your intent to just have this happen
on the seacoast
thank you representative question yes my
intent was as i spoke to earlier for it
to be coastal moorings only
because there's a distinction and i'd be
glad to entertain an amendment that the
committee might like to do to clarify
that
is
um
in inland bodies you don't have somebody
who's going to take a boat and go away
for two weeks on the on a local lake
on the in the coastal environment that
is more common
therefore whatever never moorings don't
have a boat on them during the summer
that number is greater when people that
bought their boat to use it
to
travel the coast
um it'd be open more than it would be
otherwise
thank you
any any other
representative vegan for a question
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
uh
not being a boat owner does the
mooring permit
have any language in it that requires
the owner of the permit to
compensate on any liability that might
occur of damage and it's mooring if you
know
no um
and i'd have to we look at the um i
don't currently hold a mooring in the
state i am a boater
um and so i don't recall if they if the
port requires insurance or not some do
some don't the
the property that you
again the real property
at the mooring location is has is
provided by
the permit holder the state doesn't
provide that therefore the state doesn't
have any liability on that and any
prudent voter knows that you should
check your ground tackle and ensure that
it's adequate to hold the boat because
there is
corrosion in um
over time um chains weaken in in
rust out so
um
that's really
the responsibility of the permit holder
and the boat owner to ensure that they
have adequate
you know system that's going to hold
them
follow-up
actually my question is for the chair do
we presume
chief dunleavy will be testifying on
this uh he will be testifying so i'll
hold my question then for him thank you
very much thank you mr chairman
representative mayville
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking the question
i'm wondering who you envision is going
to develop the permit process the form
is it will be electronic and then who
again will oversee the process as it
unfolds um between the existing owner
and the transferee
okay so i don't envision there being a
form i envision this being quite a quite
simple
agreement
so
currently again on coastal moorings the
port authority
has a form you fill out as the permit
holder
and in the i'm pretty sure it's on the
form but it's in the language if you go
to the rsa that
currently it's explicitly
prohibited to
allow somebody to use your mooring
period so this again would be
you as a permit holder would decide if
somebody can use your mooring and who it
is but it
would not require
additional paperwork or additional
permit to be issued
welcome
representative
creighton
uh thank you mr chairman representative
uh thank you and and
you know clearly trying to make things
easier to visit new hampshire makes
sense um
my question though is
so you're
what we're authorizing then is a bill
that says
that a bone owner that owns a mooring
can have a handshake
with someone to say hey come on use my
mooring
if if i'm the
port authority
how do i know that that boat is changed
if there's no coordination with the port
authority paperwork or anything like
that and so therefore how do i
how do i know that that handshake has
occurred
thank you representative for the
question
well again the port authority has the
knowledge of who the permit holder is
and
the description length
draft of the boat and so forth
so the port authority
could contact the permit holder
if they were concerned that
somebody was on that mooring that didn't
have
the right to use it
really what this does again it opens it
up for the permit holder
with pretty much very
limited restrictions
to use that mooring without um
so
i mean i guess
probably the biggest question that
may come to mind is well how do you know
if the 30 days
has been used up and again it's
um
something that if anybody's paying
attention what boat's on there and they
see one
on there that's a different description
than what the permit holder has
for a long period of time that they can
you know law enforcement could
not take that boat it was there day
after day after day again this is
meant to be a temporary basis hence the
30 days
but i envisioned in reality that it'd
probably be less than that a weekend
maybe maybe three or four days and by
the way this is something that does
occur i'm a member of a boat actually
sail club and this does occur throughout
the
coast and and so it's done without any
major problems the way i understand it
because i've used moorings in other
places that
members of the club
uh allowed what they do they put out the
list and say i'm going to be gone again
on this date for a week two weeks
whatever it is if you want to use it
you're welcome to use it
okay thank you
anyone else for a question
representative post for a question thank
you mr chair and thank you um
representative
um so i am looking at
section 270
67.
and
no mooring shall be sold or at least
except as provided in this section
so
this would affect
this is where
it would come to the attention of the
port authority by changing this
so they would know that
owners of these moorings now have the
ability to have someone there and maybe
not um
you know check these moorings regularly
because now they know that that these
folks have
the ability to
in essence
lease for free
their spot
is that correct thank you for the
question and i would believe yes that's
true and again if you look at the
language what this does is it
it
under line one through two transfer
mooring permits rsa 270
colon 63 is repealed and reenacted to
read as followers
270 63 transfer of mooring permits one a
mooring permit shall not be construed as
ownership of any real personal property
the whole of the mooring permit may
transfer such permit to a different
person for use for up to 30 days so that
that's the authority to do this that
where it's um
the language in lines one through
actually four
well
representative mayville and
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i know nothing about these moorings
but i know a little bit about boats and
i'm wondering if there's some limitation
on the draft the draw the breath the the
size of the boat that would exist in a
mooring and if that could be potentially
i mean i think this sounds like a good
idea but would that be a complication if
you know i've got my little baby yacht
right here and someone comes in the
50-foot one next door and
is there some restriction on the what
goes into the mooring and that's why
there are these permits
thank you representative for the
question the reason for permits is to
have an
orderly
process to make sure moorings are placed
in an area where
boats that are in the same moon field
don't
interfere with each other when there's a
title change
in indoor wind
shift where there's enough what we call
swing room
that boats won't hit other boats in to
your question
yes some moorings have in the port
ask for this information on the
application
the length of your boat and the dr in
the draft and so forth so when they
issue you a permit when you come up
on getting a location
that they issue you one that
has a the appropriate room so having
said that
you as a permit holder will obviously
you know relay that information anybody
that you let use it
and a prudent mariner is going to ensure
that
they
don't put their boat in harm's way and
so
sometimes it's obvious sometimes it's
not but
again to clarify there are some warnings
that the swing room would only allow say
a 25-foot boat or 30-foot boat others
that would allow a 50-foot boat
in new hampshire most of those mooring
fields now once you get over 40 feet
they're getting restricted it's harder
it's less and less of those to
to have the
proper space
anyone else for and any other members of
the committee
for a question
seeing none
thank you very much thank you mr chair i
didn't believe i didn't realize there
was going to be so much interest in the
in the bill i appreciate it
there wasn't a lot happening in the
other one so they just got it all backed
up
you know they had to let it all out
the chair calls uh
captain dunlevy from the marine patrol
thank you mr chairman tim dunleavy i'm
captain with the marine patrol for the
division of state police
and uh i was going to ask to
respectfully withdraw my card as
i learned just before this hearing
that this applied to coastal moorings
only and the department of safety marine
patrol have no jurisdiction uh over the
coastal moorings that is the the
oversight of the new hampshire port
authority
uh i will and do express a bit of
concern where this cites uh chapter 270
where that chapter does specifically
address inland moorings and it doesn't
seem to be clear
and and as representative connors uh
mentioned in her question to
representative trojan or maybe it was
his representative post
in speaking to the transfer the charging
and leasing of moorings
those statutes do not apply to the
coastal moorings it's a whole separate
oversight
and whether it's by rule or statute i
can't speak to that
but certainly
department of safety would have concern
if some of this language found its way
into chapter 270 and applied to inland
moorings so uh while i recognize
representative teroshan's request for
coastal application makes complete sense
to me
but i just don't know uh the ins and
outs of the regulations down there
happy to answer any questions if you
would have some
representative smith for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you thank
you captain dunleavy so as the bill is
written it is not
doing what the sponsor wants it to do
by addressing the statute the 270
statute
which is inland waterways
thank you for your question
i do not know where the authority and
the regulations for the coastal moorings
are whether it's by rule or statue
uh what i do know is is 270 would apply
to inland moorings and i and i after a
discussion with him it's obviously not
his intent and so that's why i would
have no no opinion department station
would remain neutral other than we would
have concern if that type of language
showed up without clarification in the
270 chapter
thank you
yeah any other questions by members of
the committee
representative post for a question
where would someone go to find that
information
to make to perhaps make an amendment
to that
representative thank you for your
question i would contact the port
authority uh i suspect that had they
been here today they could shed more
light on on all this issue
um
would be director marconi down at the
port authority
thank you
representative egan for a question thank
you mr chair
thank you captain i apologize i called
you chief before my apologies um
within your purview of inland
moorings
does a permit holder have when they get
a permit have liability
to
the mooring do they have to have
insurance for their mooring for their
their
boat as it relates to when they apply
for the permit or a condition of getting
a permit
thank you for your question
representative uh no there is no
insurance requirement uh for
boats or boats on moorings or moorings
but certainly we have been
requested to provide reports
after moorings breakaway boats break
away
for civil action
quick follow-up
so follow-up
so if a
boat does cause
or
ill-tied up boat does cause damage to a
mooring area or to a
inland
dock area who
is responsible for that is there
language in the permit about any kind of
responsibility
there is not
the
and it does happen particularly with
someone who is negligent in checking the
condition of their tackle as
representative terosha mentioned
and we're tested every year two or three
times a year
after a front comes through and we get a
real choppy day on our big lakes some of
those we can chains break away and the
boats go down the lake and cause damage
when they reach the shoreline
it's a civil matter with no requirements
thank you very much thank you
any other questions from members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much and
seeing no other
having no other pink cards
i will declare this
hearing adjourned
and
[Music]
we'll the next hearing is
15. got 15 minutes
anywhere
for the next one
oh
i know
thank you
foreign
they're doing a better job
is
it should
be yeah
okay
uh
so of course
is
you
there you go now
call the
hearing to order for house bill
1641 fn relative to
vessel registrations
uh
representative
trottier
uh you need ten minutes to speak uh
that's kinda
yes sir all right well uh if that okay
uh good morning mr chair and members of
this fine committee
my name is douglas trottia i'm a
representative of district six
serving the town of belmont
this issue was not on my radar until it
was brought up by my town administrator
border slutman and a few constituents
in my community
so
what we're
with this bill what i'm trying to do
is
where boats right now are only being
registered by the foot
not the value of the boat at the time
as
most ivs or campers are it's not by the
foot it is by
the value
so my border seletman and town
administrator asked me if i could enter
a bill
to um
have
boats on the same level as ivs for
registration so that they are um
registered at their value not the foot
because you could have a two or three
hundred thousand dollar vote
that you're paying a minimal amount to
register it whereas if you buy a camper
at the same um
value you're probably paying thousands
of dollars to register it here in the
state
so basically that's it i have spoken to
members of the boating association i
believe it is and even
marine patrol
and they understand what i'm trying to
do we feel that there could be some work
on this and i have no problem if we
could set up a committee and work with
them and come up with something that's
feasible for everyone
so that's pretty much my testimony if
anybody's got any questions i will try
to answer them to the best of my ability
representative post uh followed by
representative connor
thank you when you're registering a
vehicle um
in this state we have anything before
is vastly reduced would that be part of
this
yes that would be my goal
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question who would determine
the value of the boats and does it
depend on engines and all kinds of other
pieces um i believe it would be the same
way as a vehicle they'll look at the
purchase or the value of the vehicle at
the time that there would be a book
um and then determined that way and
depreciation probably like a normal
vehicle
every year it goes down a certain amount
any other questions
seeing none
thank you very much that was a fast 10
minutes thank you
chair calls
jeff
albert inc
representing the
dmv i presume that's the department of
motor vehicles
department vision okay
i upgraded it all right downgrade sorry
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
jeff overdank and i'm here to
provide testimony today in opposition to
this bill and not because we don't
believe the mill rate system doesn't
work we've registered some 1.6 million
vehicles
via the mill rate system last year
the issue becomes at where the mill rate
comes in for boats and starting at a
mill rate of 18
would make it an unaffordable
pastime for folks i mean i think one of
the things that makes it
new hampshire a great landing spot for
boating is that it is
a reasonable rate in which to register
your boat
and for some historical purpose here
in 2019 we registered some 95 000 boats
in 2020 we registered a record 103 000
votes
and
last year in 2021 we eclipsed that with
107 000
boat registrations
and we are seeing a number of folks from
other states registering their boats and
using them here in new hampshire because
number one it's a great place to be but
it is a value to register your boat
under the current system
uh
having said that when people register
their boats and they travel here to use
them it's they're they're purchasing gas
here they're stopping at our restaurants
they're staying in the hotels
and bringing the mill rate up as high as
this bill calls will
absolutely cut the number of
registrations uh drastically in our
estimation
that's something that we have seen over
the past few years people are taking
advantage of
a boating in a great place and doing so
where it's affordable and we think this
bill
backs that sends that backwards
having said that i know there was a
question earlier
reference how is the value determined
and value is determined through
administrative rule it is using the red
book
same thing as a kelly blue book there
are a couple of reference guides out
there and
having checked or researching the bill
red book does determine
the value
of boats as well
having said that i'll conclude my
testimony and answer any questions
from the committee that you may have
okay
representative smith for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
can you give me
just a couple of examples of what the
price difference would be on a couple of
boats if you had a boat that you
purchased for a hundred thousand dollars
and it's new
what they would pay now or versus what
they would pay by the 18 mil rate
sure there's actually not to steal the
testimony from the association coming up
next they have some of those examples
for you
okay so you'll defer to them we'll defer
to them thank you
any other
any other members of the committee have
uh questions for the witness
seeing none thank you very much if you
have do you uh have any written
testimony or anything uh no written
testimonies okay fine thank you
chair calls
peter mccallum
representing the new hampshire marine
trades association
and
you have already passed out some
some testimony is that yours
is is your microphone on
oh there you go how's that that's better
also it it gets out to the people who
are listening on youtube excellent
uh thank you mr chairman and members of
the committee i've edited some of my
testimony here based on the fact that
some of the data was reviewed by the
previous testimony
i think i'll take four to five minutes
of your time
for the record my name is peter mccallum
i am the sole owner of mccallum's
boathouse here in new hampshire on
northwood lake in epsom
uh
mccallum's is a family-owned business
that was started by my grandpa parents
in 1949.
we've been around for a long time we are
a full-service marine retail service
storage dealership
i also have the privilege of serving as
the president of the new hampshire
marine trades association
nhmta is an association of marine
industry related businesses committed to
the protection and growth of
recreational boating here in our state
we support boating safety as a platform
of our organization and serve as
stewards in our lakes and waterways to
protect the environment the health and
beauty of the new hampshire's resources
we're about 45 members deep and we have
members from the seacoast to
the north country
all the way out past keene to the
connecticut river
i'm here to testify on behalf of the
association in opposition to hb 1641
relative to vessel registration
our group believes that hp 1641 will
have a negative impact on recreational
boating in new hampshire
as what is proposed is a major change to
the formula for registration and it is a
significant increase in the cost of
registration to the consumer ultimately
our customer
specific concerns that we have from our
membership
concern number one is the impact on new
hampshire families decision to choose
boating as an activity in the summer
families have a lot of choices when it
comes to recreating in our state this
appears to raise fees significantly
without any clear direction of whether
the increase is needed and how the
monies would be spent
while this could be a short-term
increase in funding for the state
our group believes this could end up
hurting recreational voting in the long
term
number two
concern of impact
for voters that come to us from out of
state that register here it's not clear
if the increases in fees will cause some
of the out-of-state boaters who
currently register register their boats
in new hampshire to change their habits
ultimately affecting our revenue gained
from boat registrations here
number three concern of impact to boat
sales in new hampshire many dealers
benefit from massachusetts and many
other out-of-state voters that buy and
register here in our state if new
hampshire's registration fees begin to
rival the costs in other states we'll
lose out on that advantage
number four
concern of impact of local marine and
boat dealers who act as registration
agents for the department of safety
understanding such a change would
require changes in our online system
that a lion's share of our membership
uses
we simply don't know how much this
improvement
would cost our dealers and
municipalities to have our systems
updated appropriately
number five
a specific concern about the mill rate
and how it will be implemented
there are many boat manufacturers across
our country in the world the list price
may be a base model but that could
change nearly a hundred percent based on
options added by the consumer including
the engine size trailer and
customization packages
our group would like to understand and
get as much information as possible as
to how that calculation would work
in trying to estimate how much the
increase is stated would be to some of
our boating public one of our members
tried to estimate the change in the fee
understand with limited information on
the bill on how the mill system would
work
we're doing the best that we can here
but these are some
excellent examples of what it would cost
the new hampshire boater
one of the hottest markets in our field
right now is a personal watercraft their
average sale is fifteen thousand dollars
currently uh that's a twenty four dollar
registration fee for product only
that's under 16 feet that would be a 10x
increase to 270 dollars in year one 225
dollars in year two and a hundred and
eighty dollars in year three
the second most popular growth market
within the state for our industry is
pontoon boats and if you spent any time
in any waterway i think you'd agree
a sixty thousand dollar pontoon boat is
a 52 registration fee today it would be
a 20x
increase in year one which would move 52
to 1080
in year two nine hundred dollars year
three seven hundred and twenty dollars
please note that the calculations above
are simply just state registration fees
and they do not include
other boat fees that go to the town and
municipalities or any other fees that
would go to search and rescue lake
restoration and preservation funds or
public boat access funds
our membership agrees wholeheartedly
that the current fee system is outdated
and i believe the last time they were
updated
was 2009.
we don't believe 1641 is the answer
we would uh support a stakeholder group
working on this issue and reporting back
to you we would volunteer to participate
in that effort
we asked this committee to find 1641
inexpedient to legislate this is simply
too big of an increase that we believe
would harm recreational voting in our
state
and the families that choose to vote
here
thank you for your time i'd be happy to
answer any questions
representative smith for a question
didn't you
well you you uh you got put off to the
next person yeah thank you uh mr chair
and thank you mr mccallum for taking my
question
uh when you
volunteer to be part of a stakeholder
group to try to upgrade the update the
fees
is that something that you think the
legislature has to
put together or this can this be done
with possibly individuals from the
legislature in or otherwise other groups
putting it together and coming back next
year with a bill on it
excellent question i don't know how that
process would look i could tell you that
we would like to be involved in it
thank you
representative egan
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
where does new hampshire's boat fees
rank in the other six of the six new
england states are we
the most cost effective or the most
costly where do we fit in that
parameter if you know
do they have a ribbon for fifth place so
maine is driven off of sales tax and
value um
same for massachusetts connecticut
uh rhode island and vermont are
modest fees online with what we've got
but there's there's no question that new
hampshire gleans the least amount of
revenue for vote registration within new
england follow up mr church
knowing that we are our second largest
uh tool of our economy is tourism
would fee changes you think affect the
fact that voters would come here from
other states maybe they do now
so you're saying we have a lesser fee
unquestionably
thank you sir
any other questions for members of the
committee
seeing none
thank you very much thank you
the chair calls
captain dunlevy from the marine patrol
thank you mr chairman honourable members
of the committee my name is tim dunleavy
captain with the marine patrol unit of
the division of state police
i thank you for the opportunity to
testify this morning and i won't
reiterate what folks before me have said
but i come before you in opposition of
this bill
i will reserve my comments to a couple
of little threads that you may have
heard
by a couple of folks already in that
perhaps it's time to look at the way new
hampshire registers at spokes well we're
not in favor of the proposed mill rate
we believe that there is some room to
apply a mill rate
process to the boat registration fees
what that would be we think there is a
lot of room for discussion
our concern though lies in some other
areas that a lot of folks don't realize
where the revenues go that are generated
by boat registrations
we are a user pays user benefit system
when it comes to the registry boat
registration process and what i mean by
that is
when you
pay the overall i'll use the term
overall expense to register your boat
there are numerous
agencies that benefit from those those
revenues
to include the towns in which that boat
has been registered in
and if you look at
the marine patrol budget operation
budget we receive a portion of the
overall revenues
there is a registration fee in chapter
270e
but there's also the boat fee in rsa 72a
significantly different by the way 72a
is a much larger amount in most cases
and depending upon where you register
your boat if you register with the
department of safety
or through the marine patrol or the dmv
not only does the registration fee but
the boat fee comes to the navigation
safety fund the marine patrol budget
but if you register with a marina or a
town hall
that boat fee the larger portion of the
overall expense stays with the town
and folks are realizing that there is a
windfall to be had here in towns
where there's an advantage
and
we are hearing
more and more with every passing year
why can't we renew our boat online
we can do it for everything else these
days sit at the computer and renew our
boat online
selfishly
if we allow that to happen and they do
it through a town portal
those revenues would go to the town and
we're fearful that that convenience
may seriously impact what the department
of safety's operating budget for marine
patrol
would would
experience
these are all things that we recognize
we don't want to pull from out from
underneath the towns
but we want to look at what is the fair
application of how these these
revenues
are split up and used
my final comment in perhaps most
concerning is about half of our budget
is operating budget comes from the coast
guard voting safety grant
those were those that grant is based on
on fees generated at the federal level
for behind the scenes excise taxes
for fishing equipment
boat safety equipment
road tax fuel tax off-road tax
all of those things are dispersed
amongst 56 states not only boating
safety agencies but fish and game
agencies wildlife agencies as well
with every federal grant comes
requirements
and interestingly
federal code
says that we are not allowed to
charge or attach
any fees outside of a boat registration
to the consumer when they want to
register their boat
new hampshire is in violation of that
code because we are collecting numerous
fees lake restoration fund which which
helped the fight of aquatic invasives
public access
fees
search and rescue fees
dredging fees
so these these ancillary fees that are
attached to that registration process
are a violation of federal code and the
coast guard has put us on notice that we
need to work to somehow remedy that
so i come before you
echoing what some folks have said before
me maybe it's time that we we look at a
process to get all stakeholders involved
um to look at what is the fair and
applicable changes that we can make
um and and not necessarily
raise the fees to the rate that
this bill before you today would
but but to look at the overall uh
process and and and make the towns
marine patrol des fishing game the port
authority all happy
and with that i'm happy to answer any
questions
any questions by members of the
committee
representative smith
yeah thank you mr chair thank you
captain for uh taking my question
so
i just want to make sure i have this
right
so
we have the registration which this bill
applies to
and then we have the add-ons for fish
and game search and rescue for the ais
for lakes preservation
and that if we want federal grants
that's not legal and they're going to
cut us off
um they are willing to allow us time
to remedy that
there is no threat to cut us off but
certainly it is a condition to comply
with those federal codes
in order to receive federal dollars
for a follow-up how much time
um
how long do we have if we're showing
progress i'm comfortable in saying that
they will uh i'll use the expression
stay off our back as long as we're
showing uh good faith and progress thank
you
okay
representative post for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
captain
um
so my question is do you have
any suggestions of how you would
approach this
for a bill to be put forth or do you see
this more
as
what mr mccallum had said a group
getting together
and doing that
independently and then making
a bill out of that certainly i think the
bill before you today needs to be
separate from that process
uh however if there is a bill next
session to to form a study
committee or commission uh or if if
there are members of this committee and
others uh other legislators that might
like to become part of a stakeholder
group where
where folks i think from marine trades
um
the the town clerks um all of those
folks des the other state agencies all
need to i would recommend have a seat at
that table so that all
concerns are are addressed
marinas would love to go online it'll
save them uh pulling staff away at the
counter on 4th of july weekend memorial
day weekend but at the same time they
want to offer this important service
brings people into their showrooms and
it's a service that many of them provide
their customers that is much appreciated
we have some towns i won't mention them
specifically but
they don't have a single acre of public
waters in their town and yet their town
clerks are registering boats receiving
this significant amount of money
that that is not going back to that user
pays benefits
intent that that you folks at the
legislature set up for us
uh back in the early late 90s
for a follow-up
um and perhaps this is
more ass
to our chair but
having that stakeholder group
would
allow us not to have to fund
a study
that's a question
and not being familiar
aside from from from sitting on some of
those studies i don't know the
background process uh and what all and
is involved to to fund something like
that or to spin that up
but but i will say that i think the
issues
behind boat registrations are important
enough to be heard by you folks and and
and for all those stakeholders to to be
heard
whether that avenue is a stakeholder
group that presents a report or an
actual commission that files a report um
it's it's it's time some of these issues
are pretty ripe and uh and everybody has
should have the opportunity to weigh in
one more
follow-up please for a follow-up
so have you had it ever had an
opportunity to have a stakeholder group
like that working with the legislature
that isn't
a study that gets
i personally have not been involved with
one but i'm sure they've existed
well
you've had there are there are
there have been
there's stakeholder groups throughout
you know with the one on
[Music]
docks
again had stakeholders in it and
yeah this is not this is not unique
any other questions
members of the committee
if not
thank you very much thank you all for
your time thank you
and seeing no other pink cards
i'll declare the
your hearing adjourned on uh 14
16 41.
the next uh
day hearing is
after lunch
it will be on 12th we're continuing on
12 27 it was
prime wetland we uh
had planned to this is a continuation of
that
that uh
bill
uh we had
planned this to be have that the the uh
prime sponsor was ill
uh at uh uh at the time
and sees he is still
ill and will not be here so
we will i will open the hearing and i
will take whatever testimony is is
available if
but i do not i think it's
do not believe that it will be that long
a hearing at
f at one o'clock
being that seeing that thank you very
much
all right i'd like to uh call the
meeting uh
to order for our
a continuation of the public hearing on
uh
from 112 on house bill
12 27 excuse me relative to definition
of prime wetland
uh
the
primary reason that uh
continued the meeting
was in deference to the uh
the
the uh
the prime sponsor
uh he was who was uh
ill uh assuming that he would was ill at
the time assuming that he will
uh
he would be
better
unfortunately that's not true so he will
not be here uh
but i will take uh testimony and uh
uh from anyone who wishes to give it uh
but uh
uh
but unfortunately my best intentions did
not work out well
so with that uh the chair recognizes
representative suzanne smith
thank you mr chair and uh nice to be
here on the other side of the table from
all of you
for the record i'm suzanne smith and i
serve the towns of plymouth hebron and
holderness in grafton eight and i wrote
and i am here today in support of house
bill 1227 which amends the prime
wetlands statute but first i'd like to
talk a little bit about wetlands
generally
wetlands provide a valuable service to
society and the environment besides
sustaining a huge number of plant and
animal species they can improve water
quality reduce erosion and prevent
flooding
those who use the term swamp to describe
wetlands which they are
keep in mind that the dredging and the
destruction of the delta swamps i.e the
wetlands in louisiana made it far easier
for rising waters to flood new orleans
wetlands there with their mangrove trees
and bushes which thrive in the wet areas
shield the uplands the dry areas further
upstream
where i live there are many steep slopes
streams which usually trickle down the
mountain then they become roaring brooks
after a heavy rain and then they join
other larger brooks and these then crash
towards our pristine newfound lake
but before dragging sediment down the
mountain it through the brook and into
the lake a large wetlands complex lies
in the water's path the water spreads
out it slows down stopped in its tracks
by the wetland the lake is protected and
the wetlands prevent flooding filter out
any debris whether it's leaves and silt
or toxins from overwhelmed septic
systems higher up in the watershed
call them swamps bogs or marshes they're
all wetlands they minimize flooding
protect our lakes and rivers and provide
valuable habitat for wildlife
prime wetlands which are defined in rsa
482 a15 only apply to wetlands two acres
or more in size they are a local option
no prime wetlands can be put into place
without the town voting on it
and passing
passing the ordinance
since the first prime wetland statute
passed in 1991
33 towns have adopted prime wetlands it
is not an easy process towns are
required to perform an extensive review
hold public hearings after notifying all
abutters and then finally vote on
whether to designate a specific prime
wetland
then after all of this work des reviews
all of their documentation including the
town's vote and then they approve or
deny the designation
hospital 1227 restores status of the
edges of the small connecting streams
which are sometimes called fingers and
toes it excludes ditches and culverts
which we heard from d.o.t is something
they were happy with
this component of the statute excluding
the fingers and toes was removed in
2012.
and i want to uh end with a quick quote
from certified wetland scientist dr rick
vandepole who between 1991 and 2012
assisted many of the towns who passed
prime wetland ordinances
please keep in mind and this is from dr
van der pol please keep in mind that
passing this bill will not ensure that
every town in the state will do this it
still takes a lot of hard work lots of
consultant fees state approval of very
specific maps and the consent of a
majority of the voters in the town
so thank you for your consideration
and i hope you will support this bill
thank you
is there any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much for
julia do you have anything to submit to
the board
your testimony
okay
the only other pink card i have is uh
kevin nyan
department of transportation if you wish
to speak
all right thanks sorry about that thank
you mr chairman members of the committee
for the record kevin nyan uh department
of transportation and i did testify
i think a couple of weeks ago now
also expecting that representative
grassy would be here today
and at the time i testified in support
of the bill
and
it's been a number of years now that the
department worked with representative
grassy on getting the language included
i think it's lines 21 and through 23 of
the belt the bill that deals
specifically with prime wetlands in the
context of the state right-of-way
uh and since that time you know and it
was
reflected again after uh the last uh the
beginning of the the hearing
that there are a number of folks who
have been testifying uh in opposition to
the bill and i understand their position
and though for the last number of years
the our language i would
that we worked on specific to dot has
kind of gone along with the bill and
gone along with the bill and and i i
haven't heard any specific testimony
opposing the language that we worked to
include i think most folks recognize
that that will that that language uh
represents
a burden to the department that you know
isn't necessary uh for the work that we
do and so i guess my ask and
continuation of my original testimony
would be that not knowing if this is
improper or not or or how it works for
you folks that
if
you know if in your deliberations
following the hearing when you're
exacting the bill
if you find it
that the bill that the bill would likely
be in exceeding to legislate that you
consider
um retaining the language at the at the
bottom of the bill the d.o.t language
so that we're you know we we don't uh
if and when
um if the bill is found and expedient to
legislate at least the d.o.t language
that folks have not had opposition to
wouldn't necessarily need to be you know
brought up year after year so i'm not
speaking to the validity and of the
science or of um or or of
um
you know the original language uh
whatever whatever happens with the bill
whatever the definition is of prime
wetlands obviously the department will
follow that definition but it would be
helpful if we were able to retain that
language should the committee find the
bill and expedient to legislate so with
that i conclude my testimony and i'm
happy to answer any questions that you
might have
any questions by members of the
committee for
for the uh
for the speaker
thank you i will offer if it's helpful
to the committee if you'd like something
written i can follow up with something
written for the file no that would be
fine okay that would be good thank you
thank you
seeing
having seen no more pink cards and
seeing no more hands no one no one
moving toward the pink card table
then i will uh
call a call the meeting uh adjourned a
friend 12 continuing meeting on 12
27 is adjourned
thank you and i apologize
for uh foreign
allowing him
for having the meeting but you know no
good
no good indeed bill's unpunished thank
you
we will uh be uh
we will schedule executive sessions on
uh on the bill at a future date
yep
when the next hearing will be
fn at 1 45.
you
all right good afternoon i'm calling the
next session house bill 1554
fn an act relative to online payment of
fees and fines
relating to the operation of off highway
recreational vehicles and snowmobiles i
believe our first speaker and testimony
will be from the prime sponsor
representative tim egan representative
egan
i need to remove my mask so i can not
have my glasses fog up
thank you mr chair thank you committee
for hearing me today to speak on behalf
of house bill 1554 um
it is relative to the online payment of
fees and fines relating to the operation
of off-highway vehicle recreational
vehicles and snowmobiles
the fish and game department touches
many new hampshire residents and
visitors who are outdoor enthusiasts and
the modernization of our state's
infrastructure will go a long way in
serving this community with convenience
data research and education
offering hunters fishermen and a variety
of motorized riders the ability to pay
for registrations in advance of their
trip is essential with the busy lives
they all have this creates convenience
and increases the opportunity for people
to follow the rules it allows ohrv
riders to register in advance of the
season helping fish and game estimate
ridership prepare for enforcement fast
staffing demands
it gives snowmobilers an opportunity to
register their sled before coming up the
night of a big snowstorm or an angler
whose license has lapsed and be and has
become an offender accidentally has the
opportunity to pay their fine once they
leave the state and that keeps us from
losing revenue while tracking
infractions for future awareness and to
be able to run changes of rules and
program education to those
via an online communications and this
bill does not do away with the
time-honored tradition that people
will have going to the do their
registration at their local club or
getting a license at their neighborhood
base shop it just adds the modern
web-based infrastructure world that
those who prefer to utilize that message
can now do so
this bill is important in supporting our
valuable tourism economy easing burden
on small businesses modernizing our
transaction process for the consumer and
the agency and supporting our
understaffed hardworking fish and game
department i see it as enabling
legislation done in consultation with
fish and game and the communities that
they serve
and this is a simple bill that has a
tremendous positive impact on new
hampshire residents and
our visitors who come to enjoy our
mountains woods lakes streams and trails
as well
in further conversation with fish and
game i did also create an amendment if
you feel that this bill is worthy
for discussion executive session which i
have handed out to you which actually
clarifies a timeline for the online
process to be taken into consideration
given fish and game has some
vendor contract rules that they have to
follow and it gives them more time to be
able to process the development of this
online system
thank you so much glad to take any
questions
actually my first question is do you
have any more copies of the amendment
i apologize
okay
anyone else have it representative smith
actually now i have a real question
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
so presently um
stores
you know do
provide registration
for your ohrv or snowmobile
and
so who gets the funds collected on the
registration if they purchase it at like
my local hebron village store
versus if they would be doing it online
so the funds still go to the state but
there are clubs that do registrations
and therefore you can get discounts if
you're a member of a club
so that information will be factored
into the online system this again is why
the amendment is to give the fish and
game department more time to make sure
that they accurately
work with the snowmobile association and
the ohrp associations who have the list
of those clubs and members
yeah
so i guess the question is do stores get
that are providing that service of
registering your ohrv or snowmobile do
they get a cut
of the funds i will probably
defer to someone from fishing games will
be more specific about how the internal
revenue uh is distributed okay thank you
any other questions for the
representative
representative creighton
yes sir thank you and representative
thank you appreciate it um
do we have to do this i mean can't fish
and game just they've already i mean i
bought my license two days ago online
this can't be added to their current
system you bought your license for
fishing and hunting right they can do
that now they cannot do that for ohrv
and snowmobile and we have to order them
to do that i'm sorry for a follow-up
again i'll defer to the law enforcement
officials at fish and game regarding the
have to i don't i do think we have to
enable them
okay all right
thank you
thank you any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you representative
thank you mr chair
since there were some questions for fish
and game our next speaker will be
captain eastman from fish and game
in support of the bill with an amendment
10 minutes
captain eastman welcome
mike
originally the
commission was not in favor of the way
that this was written just due to the
fact that it would give us 60 days to
establish this
um
it was not cost would not be cost
effective for the department or for you
know really the state to to go ahead and
establish something of this nature in
that short amount of time uh with this
amendment uh pushing this out september
1st of 2025 it would allow us to do that
um so to your question about you know
purchasing a license right now
is that we have what's called an s3
is a basically a vendor that we have
that does the online licensing system
um the issue that's always been with
registrations is making sure that
obviously the eyes are dotted and the
t's are crossed um you know on that
original registration due to the fact
that
you know we do get machines that are
stolen and and
when they're sold there's some you know
the vin numbers need to be you know
accurate and things like that so um
really uh you know
allowing us to
um well and the other part of that is
that this contract with this vendor is
soon to be done in 2023 or will look to
go look for bids and vendors so to
establish something right now and then
and roll it out and then look to go to a
new vendor within six months once again
wouldn't be cost effective so
really establishing this date allows us
to go to find a vendor establish what we
need
and it would be our recommendation this
is a renewal program uh just there's
really no other online service that
allows you to register you know a motor
you can't register a brand new motor
vehicle online it's all renewal so it's
really a convenience for those that
already have a registration you'll want
to get it registered and they'll get
there you know we already have a mailing
process where they do that or can do
that
but this yeah so this would really you
know assist with that and give us some
time to establish that
so with that amendment we would be in
favor of this legislation
thank you
captain representative creighton
question
okay so
again
you from your perspective
we have to approve this bill
for you to do that you just can't say
that this is my job and i'm doing my job
and go ahead and do it
i want to answer you honestly so i'll do
that
so i originally went to our department
with this plan and asked that that we
start to get a concept for this um i
received a lot of blowback from that
from which people didn't even want to
talk to me for about a month um but i
think this would really get us in the
right position so um
unfortunately that's the way it works
and we want to get you know into the
current century that we're in now so
yes unfortunately
for a follow-on also just from a
personal note does that include uh
guides hunting and fishing guides
so i don't have to beat my way down to
your shop
unfortunately we're not there yet with
guys
sorry thank you
thank you
any other questions
representative smith
thank you and thank you captain eastman
um
are you the one who can answer my
question about
do stores uh get a get a portion of the
registration fees when people register
at a private entity
that was another issue that we had
with this with the original
writing of this bill
was that or that the commission had was
that it really didn't lay out if this
would just be contin just just online
all the way around or if it would still
be private
or
rent excuse me registration agents that
did this so um it was never our
intention that um or i globally
represented vegan's intention that
that these vendors or agents would go
away so if someone now goes to a local
let's say a local hrv snowmobile
establishment that is a registration
agent with us and registers a snowmobile
um ohrv they
are they are charged the price plus a
four dollar fee which the agent gets um
for their you know for basically their
them doing the paperwork and and
everything else and sending it in and
soon with the with the new tiered system
that will go up to five dollars
thank you um
so it's an extra fee that's tacked on
when you pay at a not right there
is that what you're saying
that's correct okay there's also a
system where you can currently register
through the mail
through fish and game
and that same
fee still apply so instead of it going
to that vendor it would come just a fish
and game
thank you
any other questions for the captain i
have one captain um
you mentioned renewal registrations only
but when i read the amendment it just
says
fines or registration fees
but you would like this only for renewal
registration
ins once again in speaking with my
licensing division registration division
um and speaking with you know the
director motor vehicle that's that's the
way we would foresee it is that the
similar program as to motor vehicle that
it would be a renewal
program um
just because once again we we need to
make sure that vin numbers and and um
you know registrations are are you know
that everything's filled out
appropriately
thank you and i just the comment to the
prime sponsor you might want to consider
amending that
any other questions for the captain
seeing none thank you captain for your
testimony thank you
next mr stephen wilkie new hampshire
ohva
mr wilkie
in favor with the amendment
uh
hi chair renzolo in committee thank you
for letting me to speak on behalf of new
hampshire off highway vehicle
association
we developed our online membership
program in 2018
and have sold close to 10 000
memberships online uh each year
and
it's been a little embarrassing
that uh online people can join a club
but yet they can't register their ohrv
online
i understand initial registrations takes
a lot of information to put in and
we certainly
agree that it should only be the
renewals to keep the data pure
and
fully support it with the amendment to
put it out until july 1st 2024
thank you
thank you mr wilkie any questions from
mr wilkie
seeing none thank you for your testimony
next witness will be mr dan banette
new hampshire new hampshire auto dealers
association
supports the bill with amendment uh good
afternoon members of the committee uh
thank you for letting me speak today my
name is dan bennett i'm with new
hampshire automobile dealers association
we're a trade group for the motor
vehicle industry in new hampshire about
500 businesses car truck motorcycles
snowmobile atv construction farm
equipment
today i'm here on behalf of our 30 or so
ohrv dealers
and letting you know that we support the
bill especially if it is amended
to both clarify renewals as well as
extend that timeline we've had multiple
conversations with the sponsor
as well as fish and game
nova and new hampshire snowmobile
association on the issue
and i think we're all we're all in
agreement
a dual system is necessary immediate on
the spot registration for ohrv
snowmobiles atvs
whether it's last-minute decisions to
come to the fishing derby because
there's actually ice when no one thought
there was
a storm happens to track a little more
northwest
than people thought and on friday night
they're lined up at the snowmobile
dealer in concord to get their
registrations because you could actually
ride in merrimack county on a saturday
when you didn't think you were supposed
to be able to so a dual system is
necessary
we agree also as what captain eastman
referred to
that initial check of the individual is
who they are they're registering
accurate units that they do in fact have
a club membership if that's what they're
going for so renewals is a great idea
i have
a handout that i'll pass to the
committee and it does in fact include
our suggestion um
and it's one word simply repeated two
times and it's renewals uh just right in
front of uh the registration fee um
that's proposed so you can see it it's
it's highlighted there um
so with that being said um those two
quick amendments to the bill and we are
supportive of this um it is a great way
to move forward uh it'll be great
customer service especially for some of
our out-of-state folks who know they're
coming up from rhode island two weeks in
early two weeks in advance they can
register their units get them in the
mail and then they're ready to ride when
they get here so
it's a great idea and it's a great
forward moving program so with that i'll
take any questions if there are any
thank you mr bennett any questions for
mr bennett
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
next in our last pink card brian labrie
new hampshire snowmobile association
supports the bill
maybe with amendment i think
mr labrie
thank you mr chair
um these guys have said it
in front in front of that came in front
of me um
we do believe that it's it's important
to have an online registration presence
here in the state
vermont maine
canada
left right north and south seem to have
this we don't
i think if we could come in line with
the times it would it would certainly
help
grow registrations in the state and
effectively boost some tourism too
the sooner the better is our opinion on
this we do realize that there's a
timeline and a platform change coming
from fish and game which we are good
with
so we are in 100
agreement with the bill as written i
think they just needed me one amendment
and
we're good
just so i can clarify or you can clarify
mr labrie you're in favor of the bill as
amended with the renewals put in also
we would like to
i guess
investigate the renewal component a
little bit more
uh we can speak offline with that with
the representative
we are in favor on 100 of online
registrations
we would like to investigate
a little bit
more
renewals versus
initial registrations we understand the
reasoning behind it for verification
purposes
sometimes it's not easy to do that
registration
i guess in a ahead of time like like the
previous gentleman stated that it's
important that when these lines build at
these these dealers sometimes it takes
away from that dealer
uh performing their other clerical tasks
helping other customers out so
if you have to verify all of these
sometimes it's uh
taxing
thank you questions for mr labrie
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
is there anyone that wants to speak that
hasn't yet put in a pink card
no more pink cards captain eastman would
you mind coming forward again one of the
representatives has another question for
you if you'll take it representative
smith
thank you captain eastman um all this
talk of uh registrations um but i do
note that it also the bill also calls
for the paying of fines online
is that uh is there any issue with that
or is that something that's easier to
deal with than registrations
the issue that uh that we have with
paying fines um and i think this
and i can't speak to um to this side i
guess of of the intent but i think it
was intense for us to
we go through issues with right now um
when a violation is
submit or is issued that's it's
basically handled by the court
in the court system having difficulty
that it is now is that we um
you know we don't believe that some of
the funds um just getting back some some
of the notifications um has been
difficult um so this would certainly
help us
but
this is a this is a criminal i think
we'd you know we'd have to look at it a
lot more before we um
made that change you know possibly
decriminalizing some things making them
civil um and then there would be a lot
more that that like hearings officers
and things like that we would have to
look into so um you know once again uh i
think that portion of this bill for us
we would need to look at it a lot more
before um you know we'd have to oppose
it this time and have to look at it a
lot more before we said we could
actually you know take on that part of
it
so the bill the the law that we passed a
couple of years ago three years ago
maybe increasing the fines
and so as far as i don't know if we
changed them from violations to
misdemeanors or if they were always
misdemeanors but is that something that
would need to come back to the
legislature to approve if you were
changing the class of the
of the violation
certainly the increase in the fee has
not has it was not the issue that
certainly i think helped out in a lot of
areas especially off trail writing and
registrations and things of that nature
in my opinion um
i'm not you know once again i i don't
i'm not sure if you know decriminalizing
making thing you know making certain
violate are certain statutes civil so
therefore we could have an internal
collection of fees and
and um hearings in-house or you know
right now
for instance you know with with motor
vehicle tickets um if you issue a ticket
it goes straight to the department of
motor vehicle and then if someone
decides that they want to have a trial
on that then
you know whomever is collecting that
that you know ticket at motor vehicle
then you know makes contact with the
court it basically takes a lot of the
court portion of it out and is just the
the uh the
person calling the court saying this
person wants a trial and they set it up
and then they send that to the person so
i i'm not sure which one would be better
for us and i think you know
our commission or my commission and
director you know taking a look at that
would be would be better okay thank you
any other questions for the captain
before we release him
representative mayville then
representative creighton
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i might have missed
it did you mention the number of initial
registrations versus the renewals
do you have an idea is it per annual or
registrations are very predicated on
weather so saying you know what's new
obviously um
with
with inventory right now
you know certainly there aren't a lot of
new registrations i'm kind of guessing
i'm seeing we're seeing a lot of
registrations but to say you know these
are brand new machines they might be
brand new owners um but i don't think
that i i can't give you like a real
number on what how many are brand new
um
i i mean i get all the pa you know it's
it it really all depends um and then
ohrv is once again you know it's there's
a trend from four wheelers to side by
side so you know there might be more
that are from one year to the next
representative crichton
yeah thank you mr chairman uh kevin
smith the
i'm just trying to clarify what i've
heard because i think
what you just said is different than
what we've been talking about
so
you're saying that you can't do fine
that this bill says
payment of any fines or registration
fees
and everyone has talked about
registration fees roger i got that
but fines you say
is going to be more difficult based upon
your description that you just did
so
my question is does fish and game
support this
bill as written
or does it support this bill
with an amendment that would take out
the fines portion
i think the what we've looked at the
majority we looked at is the registry
online registration and that's what
you've heard today
uh you know as far as the fines portion
of it i i once again we're not
i think it's it would be better for us
to look at which which option the two
that i laid out will be better for the
department um so
that portion of it i would say
we're you know we certainly at some
point i think would like to do that i'm
not sure that we're there yet for me if
that were to be
um studied a little bit more internally
that that would be my recommendation
no follow-up thank you
thank you
so captain eastman i have a question
just to try to clarify that so if the
bill was written and amended again to
just say
we'll set up online payment for renewal
registrations that's basically what
you're in favor of today
just renewal registrations
delete fines and add renewal
i would agree with that
i would add that if if it were so the
desire of the committee to say that that
um that we would
continue to look at the fine collection
portion of it
either online or or just internally i
mean i would certainly i believe my
commission would be in favor of that as
well okay thank you
any other questions for captain eastman
seeing none thank you captain
representative post yes thank you um
my question is um
this amendment
is unapproved so this could just be
changed
correct
it's not a okay
and and as far as the
fines go
it sounds like you really want to keep
it in there
but this would really end up being
an amendment in the future to this bill
is that my understanding
the question should be directed to
forecast captain eastman not to the
sponsor of the bill so i'm going to rule
that question you can get that answer
later from the sponsor or an executive
session but um do you have a question
you want to direct to captain eastman
no that that's fine okay thank you sorry
all right thank you captain for your
again testimony thank you and i see no
more pink cards nobody running up to the
table to speak
so i'm going to close the hearing on
house bill 1554
fn
and we'll open at 245 health bill 1498
fn thank you
you have another break
you
press the button can i ask the members
to take their seats
it's 2 45 i'm opening the hearing on
house bill 1498 fn an act establishing a
safety program for off highway
recreational vehicles and snowmobiles
i call to testify the prime sponsor
representative tim egan representative
egan
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee
i'm back for my double feature today
thank you for allowing me to speak to
house bill 1498 relative to establishing
a safety training program for off
highway recreational vehicles and
snowmobiles
i found this bill because i know that
fish and game department touches many
new hampshire residents and visitors who
are outdoor enthusiasts with motorized
vehicles and they enjoy all four seasons
that our state can offer them
and the ability to have riders be better
prepared while riding on new trails or
in new riding territories is essential
to helping fish and game manage their
ridership
a safety program will go a long way in
serving the community of writers with
increased safety and education this bill
was was developed in consultation with
the law enforcement division of fish and
game as well as with the new hampshire
rhiv association and new hampshire
snowmobile association
from my point of view
i feel we require safety training
courses in new hampshire to drive a boat
ride a motorcycle or use a hunting rifle
as these tracing courses protect our
state residents and our visitors that
come to enjoy those activities with the
weight of an atv or a side by side
ranging from 500 to 1500 pounds with the
weight of a snowmobile ranging from 400
to 600 pounds and these machines moving
at an estimated speed of 30 or 40 up to
80 miles an hour these vehicles can be
really fun but they can also be
potentially dangerous and recently
you've seen in the last year or so
accidents by new atv and some will be
riders and one that even seriously
injured one of our fish and game
conservation officers
while many writers have established
themselves as responsible knowledgeable
and cooperative because they're a member
of a club or an organization
and i thank those clubs and community
organizations for driving that logic
we also know that new writers and young
writers are the ones that are most at
risk this bill creates an opportunity
for people to learn the rules and follow
the rules in building more right or
respect for their communities the
communities that they ride in and around
and amongst most of our trail systems in
new hampshire as we know run through
easements that are granted by private
landowners a safety training program
allows fish and game to safeguard the
trail system
all riders currently enjoy
the bill is important in supporting our
valuable tourism economy easing the
burden of law enforcement and public
safety modernizing our education process
for the growing ohrville and snowmobile
ridership and supporting our
understaffed fish and game department
this is not necessarily a simple bill
but one that's valuable that can help
conservation officers while having a
tremendous positive impact on new
hampshire residents and the visitors who
come to enjoy the mountains woods lakes
streams and trails i feel it is enabling
legislation done
importantly in consultation with fish
and game and those member associations
in the communities that they serve but i
also know in consulting with them that
there are still a few things about this
bill that need to be worked on and i
want to make sure that we limit the
financial impact on writers and the
agency in terms of safety training class
fees as well as
other
important factors that go into
evaluating
what levels of ridership need to get
trained so i while i am bringing this
bill forward i'm also asking that the
committee
consider it during executive session for
interim study as well i'm also prepared
um with a draft of a study committee if
we want to discuss that in executive
session because i think that if the
committee feels that that might be a
better direction but moreover a safety
training program is something that the
industry is asking for fish and game
is asking for the community is needing
and therefore i brought this bill
forward for your consideration
i'm glad to take any questions thank you
thank you representative any questions
for the representative representative
gould
did you take into consideration people
renting a
vehicle that's one of the primary
considerations that i took into in this
thank you any other questions
representative connors
thank you mr chair and thank you for
bringing this bill forward could you
just let us know how this would impact
riders coming in from out of state
so
like any other
program where someone registers their
vehicle
to be utilized in the state
they would have uh
if they're going to sorry if they're
going to
register their vehicle in this state
because they have to do that if they're
going to write even though they might
live in another state they have to
register for use in this state they
would be required to have a safety
training program an important factor
that i want to make sure
i do not leave out
it is an um
what's the right word i want to use a
graduated program so those with more
experience and more history
could be grandfathered into the program
and really it's weighted for those who
are either new writers or younger
writers so where experience and age
sometimes is a detriment to us or who
are older it is actually a benefit to
those who are utilizing the safety
training program because they will be
considered having experience
so
just to put a fine point on your
question that
while the
folks still need to register their
vehicle for their ohrv or snowmobile in
this state
um they would need to be utilized a
safety training program again i'll also
defer that i know um folks from fish and
game will testify on this bill and
they'll maybe
clarify
my answer for your question
representative
thank you mr chairman representative in
the bill you have before
born after 1 january 1968
what
so if you're born before 68 what is that
your grandfathered into it and you don't
have to do it yeah i'm going to defer to
captain eastman from fish and game uh
who helped the particulars of creating
this bill to make sure that it follows
within fish and games existing rules of
of um
requiring age groups and who can be um
who needs to have a older person writing
with them if they're a younger person
okay thank you
any other questions for the
representative representative cohen
thank you for taking my question
on the section i just want a
clarification on the section on
snowmobile training it says that if a 12
year old passes this test
he or she is good for life as far as
taking the safety with no renewal as
they get more mature and older is that
what this means or says
i
um i'm i have to look at it
specifically
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna make my
life easy and and be
yours and be and defer to captain
eastman in terms of the specific
language on legalities
follow-on question then please
if a twelve-year-old
and this may be need to be deferred to
captain eastern as well ask you the
question
if a 12 year old
has a lifetime
training certification for a snowmobile
does this supersede any rules where a 12
year old can't drive a
snowmobile or can drive a snowmobile on
a class one two or three public road
it may be
again right it is
my i'm happy to wait for captain eastman
to attest and ask that question if the
chair desires well that question for
captain eastman thank you
any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you representative for
your testimony
call forward representative dennis
thompson co-sponsor of this bill
course and support
representative thompson
thank you mr chairman and committee
members
i'm dennis thompson i represent co-ops
district one
which essentially is about a third of
the top of the state of new hampshire
and probably the largest area that we
get snowmobiling and four-wheeling in in
the state of new hampshire
my basic concern up here is safety
we have uh
i
took out some articles uh today
from the boston globe
a local paper in vermont
the tv station in burlington vermont
covered the seven crashes
that we had this weekend
and in virtually every crash they
quote
mostly
lieutenant markey mark ober
as to the nature of the crashes and in
virtually every case
the crash is uh
indicated to be inexperience and
inattention
of the primary consider contributing
factors in many cases it's rental
machines
these rental companies rent the machines
out they i understand they show a video
and give some instruction but it's
certainly not enough we require safety
training for boating we require it for
motorcycles
and
why we haven't gotten around to
snowmobiles and ohrvs
is really beyond me at this point but my
concern is that up in the north country
right now
our tourism business is next to nil
we've we lost the year to the pandemic
at least
i think we're still losing some of that
and our tourism
is down dramatically
i don't think it helps any
that we have these injuries every
weekend and some of them require
helicopters our hote our hospital in
colebrook is very small
and they can take some of these people
in but they also have some covert
patients in
and in and out
and
in many cases they're not equipped
to handle the injuries that are
sustained so they call in the medflight
out of dartmouth
the cost of that runs around 22 000 and
up
depending on whether they need a flight
surgeon or not if they know where
they're going
it also um
really i think can be attributed to just
lack of training and almost every one of
these accidents there's some reason the
people did what they did to end up in a
crash and generally it's inexperienced
or they're going too fast
and we have
another bill in the legislature
currently
to regulate the
put a governor on the rental machines
some of our
people that rent them in the north
country have already done that of their
own volition and some
need to be pushed a little bit i guess
that's really all i have to say i do
support the bill and
i think that again
captain eastman can probably give you
more specifics on the
crashes and the reasons for them thank
you very much thank you representative
any questions for the representative
i have one question representative you
heard the prime sponsor say that he was
an executive session going to recommend
interim study do you also recommend
intimate study
uh i'm going to
follow chris's lead i
he wrote the bill i co-sponsored it
because i really believe we need some
sort of training on all these machines
um
and i'll i'll
defer to him on what he believes it
should happen thank you any more
questions for the representative no
thank you for your testimony
representative thank you
next i call back again captain michael
eastman
new hampshire fish and game
in favor with an amendment
captain eastman welcome back
thank you members committee
we are in in favor of this uh or support
this uh
bill upon with the amendment uh with the
interim study um
my commission and director feel that uh
what was presently submitted
which was app modeled after the boating
education
um with a graduated
age on when
individuals need to have
you know their certification by um and
the uh
really the the cutoff age or
grandfathering age was modeled after um
what the vermont vast system uh does
currently so um
by commission and detective director
believe that this would would they'd
like to have a little more time to look
at this see if this is actually the
model that would be
best for us um you know there are
certain components um with the program
as far as
we have an online platform and also a a
uh
in person um safety course that's that's
really done through volunteers and we
need to look at all of those um aspects
to make sure that it would all work
before
we would be thoroughly in favor of
something going forward so we think a
study would be appropriate
thank you captain any questions for the
captain
representative cohen then representative
post
captain easton just want to ask that
question
for clarification on the way the bill
stands now
if a 12 year old gets a
training
is he or she now certified for life they
know there's no refresher as they get
more mature as an adult is that correct
that is correct the current law
which that was as part of the current
law which is that uh person 12 years of
age
can take an ohrv safety course which
would then allow them to
operate
not by themselves but they would have to
be accompanied
in essence if you're 12 years old you
took this course and let's say you were
operating a snow machine you could
operate um
let's say to a road crossing so you
could actually operate on a trail with a
being accompanied if you got to a road
crossing you could actually operate that
machine across the road to the other
side of the to the trail and then
continue on
without the card
you would
with a person accompanying you would
have to stop at that road crossing you'd
have that 12 year old have to get off
they would have to
then take the machine across the road
and then the 12 euro would get back on
it
so once they get it at 12 to 4 to
basically the day before their 14th
birthday they can operate with someone
being accompanied once they become 14
and older with that card they can
operate unaccompanied um until they get
their driver's license at 16 and then
there's no real requirement for a
foreign hrv safety program
clarification question follow-up
question please
so for based on what you just said
if a 12 to 14 year old or when that 12
year old gets to 14 and doesn't need to
be accompanied
does that mean he or she can drive a
snowmobile on any class
one two or three road
unaccompanied
two sides of that question there aren't
snowmobiles really operating on one
through
through three
roadways
um
there certainly are could be trails
beside the one through three highways
but that would be considered a trail
so they couldn't actually operate on
that classification of you know a state
road
per se there are some
snowmobile trails that will come out
onto a road and travel maybe alongside
the edge of the road um i can think of
like hail road in samaritan there used
to be a large portion of that that went
up underneath the highway and then went
back into the woods
they could act because because that is
part of the trail now on the ohrv side
of it
they cannot operate on a on a roadway
um without being accompanied by somebody
until they're eight
18 and it's until they
so they couldn't operate um and without
someone that uh was 20 unless they had
someone who was 25 years of age
accompanying them basically on those
roadways
thank you for the clarification
representative post
thank you um
when we heard about the orvs
um
a few weeks ago
and it may have even been in the
last session
we were told that you couldn't put
governors
on
those off-road vehicles
is that true i mean and that was kind of
like my recollection that you couldn't
put governors on them
that
no i'm not sure um where that came from
they definitely have been governing
uh there's been some companies have been
governing snow machines and depends upon
manufacture
i know skadoo hasn't been able to
because they have a special key that you
can put in that will actually govern
snowmobiles um i know polaris is i don't
they can do it on the on the side by
side oh hrv side of it i
believe they're getting there with a
snowmobile um side of it but certainly
i know the polar the polaris side by
sides that are being operated this
summer like out of gorham those were
those were governed
to 40 miles an hour
okay um can i follow up to that so so i
wasn't really talking about snowmobiles
i was talking about the the off-road
vehicles we had talked about
previously
because this also says
ohrvs and snowmobiles so are they able
to put governors on the oh rvs
polaris has now come up with a system
where they can govern those um i'm not
sure about some of the other
manufacturers i believe they're there um
but the majority of the rentals that
we're seeing now are
polaris rentals and they are governed
and the ones
specifically out of gorham um then there
are a handful
but the one major
uh renter uh rental agent
his machines were governed
to 40 miles an hour
thank you very much
any other questions for the captain i
don't see any hands raised thank you for
your testimony captain
next witness brian labrie new hampshire
snowmobile associations mr library
labria
oh thank you for your time sir
committee
um
my name is brian labrie i am the
legislative chair of the new hampshire
snowmobile association i do have a
prepared statement here
the representative is circulating it now
we do fully support the interim study
and a little bit more time to refine
this bill
while we do support safety at the nhsa
and all of our clubs and counties
we do have some
challenges i think we need to work
through with this bill
thank you
any questions for mr labrie
i don't see any thank you mr labrie
we'll take your testimony thank you
next witness mr stephen wilkie
nhohva
mr wilkie welcome back
thank you again
nova uh had originally asked for this
type of legislation for the rental units
only because that was the main uh
issue
year after year for both summer and
winter recreational
um and
uh somehow it morphed into well it
should be just like boating
but really the ohrv climate in new
hampshire is not just like our boating
uh this happens on public lands and
private lands by
many different entities
in fact an ohrb in new hampshire is a
railway motor car
and
the cop valley rail trail club
they in order to operate their ohrvs on
the rails they have to have a safety
course and a license
it is not the ohrv safety course that we
take for atvs and snowmobiles
so
this bill as written does need a little
bit of
work before it goes on
the the other part of that is i took the
ohrv safety course in 1976
when i was 10 years old
and
so far the records of that are no longer
in existence
so
requiring it for everybody there's
people who have taken it and why would
you make them take it again
so again that should be studied a little
bit maybe there needs to be a year cut
off
and match vermont
which is 1983
and that puts those people about 38 and
in no time it'll be required for
everyone so
thank you very much
thank you sir any questions
for mr wilkie
seeing none thank you for your testimony
mr wilkie
and the last pink card i have is kyle
baker new hampshire wildlife federation
mr baker
uh good afternoon mr chair members of
the committee my name is kyle baker and
i'm here for the new hampshire wildlife
federation new hampshire wildlife
federations
is new hampshire's leading advocate for
the promotion and protection of hunting
fishing and trapping rights in new
hampshire as well as the protection of
an access to hunting fishing and
trapping
properties and opportunities
we support this bill we're thankful to
see it come come in this year
as you all know if anyone spends any
time outside new hampshire you rely on
both public and private land in order to
both whether it's hunting fishing ohrv
riding hiking just about everything
there is
and we see this as an opportunity to
continue to
protect and support private landowners
the last thing we would ever want to see
is a piece of property get posted for
nobody to be able to use it because of
there wasn't there was an issue on the
property whether it's from hunting
fishing trapping ohrv writing or
anything along those lines so you see
this as an opportunity to continue to
improve education about all folks that
are recreating outdoors and just add
another layer of protection to protect
and support the access to the private
lands that we all kind of rely on so
that's all i want to say but happy to
answer any questions
any questions from mr baker
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony thank you i have no other pink
cards is there anyone else that wishes
to speak on this
seeing none i'll close this hearing on
hb 1498 fn closed thank you next hearing
will be at 3 30 hb one four four zero
thank you
of which i have no pink cards
you
i just can't
oh thank you
on house bill
1440 an act relative to surface water
quality standards
for
perfluorinated chemicals to speak first
and
introduce this bill representative cohen
thank you representative cohen thank you
very much yes uh none of this none of
the sponsors are were able to be here to
introduce the bill so i am just putting
the bill into our front of us to start
our discussions in our public hearing
so i'll take any questions but it's not
my bill so
thank you representative i'm assuming no
one has a question for representative
cohen
thank you representative cohen
next uh witness ted dears of new
hampshire des in opposition to the bill
mr dears welcome
thank you very much mr chair members of
the committee it's a pleasure to be here
with you today i will go relatively
quickly through my testimony because i
know
you've had a long day and this is your
last hearing so i stand between you and
uh skedaddling so
i uh we'll just uh because we didn't
have a sponsor what i thought i would
just do is just talk really briefly
about what this bill would do it has
several parts and so just really from a
really high level here's the deal so um
it has really three sections one section
would put the current
mcls that we have for pfas compounds
into into statute for
surface waters uh i testified about this
last week if you recall that seemed like
ages ago uh many many bills ago i'm sure
for you all but um and basically
expressed our opposition we are
currently writing those rules right now
in fact today i was reviewing our draft
we will have an initial proposal out on
the street to get those mcls into our
surface water quality standards within a
few months that initial proposal will be
out on the streets happy to share that
as soon as it is drafted but i would
tell you today i was reviewing the draft
the second piece of this would have us
take those mcls and take a next really
major step
and i want to explain this because it's
kind of difficult to understand what
this what this is really doing but what
this would do is it would take those
mcls or something like them using the
same chemicals those same four chemicals
and would tell us to apply them to
in a way to all waters that might affect
how people consume water and fish
this is hard to explain but i'm going to
try to do it this way
so the mcls only apply to drinking water
that is water you're actually drinking
they don't apply to the other things in
which you might consume pfas
one of those ways would be to eat it
that is by eating fish which would have
been contaminated by pfas right so those
fish would have been swimming around in
water the water would have somehow been
contaminated by pfas or the sediment um
and then it would have bioaccumulate up
through the food chain and be consumed
so if you look at our water quality
standards those standards are an env wq
when you look across our our our our
table what i call our our table of
methyl ethyl death it's this big long
table it has all the chemicals that we
regulate in our surface waters
and when you look across that there's a
number of different ways in which we
look at water quality standards some of
those are ways in which
is the chemical bad for fish right
because we also shouldn't be killing the
fish themselves
so that's one set of
of
criteria
another set of criteria deals with
people who would be eating the fish
and it's not the amount that's in the
fish itself it's the amount that's in
the water that would eventually end up
in fish that would then be dangerous for
people to eat
so i want to make i hope this is kind of
clear but that's that's what this is
getting at
this is telling us to set the amount of
pfas
that can be in water
that would make it dangerous to eat the
fish
so that's what the second part of this
bill would do and then the third part of
this bill basically says
report on this report back to to the
legislature very frequently so that we
know what you're doing and then you know
go from there
so as i mentioned
we're opposed to this for a number of
different reasons and i'm addressing the
first one again really quickly is that
we're moving forward with rules right
now to put mcl's and that'll apply to
sort of you know the drinking water side
this issue of how you set a water
quality sam standard for water
based on fish consumption
is not straightforward
we do not currently have what the bill
calls for is us to develop
bioaccumulation factors that is
what is the ratio that the fish can be
in that would eventually
of the water that they're in that
eventually would be bad for fish for
people to eat those fish
those numbers do not exist
we wrote a report which i sent to you
all last week after the session on 1167
which was our plan for surface water
quality standards and in that it
identified the costs of how we would go
about trying to set
those bio bio accumulation factors these
bafs
and
the numbers in order for us to set a new
hampshire specific that is specific to
the kinds of water we have
the kinds of way that we eat fish here
and
the kinds of fish that we would actually
eat here
if we were to set that standard from
scratch by ourselves with the current
amount of science that's out there it
would be hundreds of thousands of
dollars to develop that it would take us
many years of laboratory research to do
so
epa is right now
attacking this issue
so in the past we as i mentioned we have
this big long table of methyl ethyl
death right has all these different
chemicals in it
all of those numbers that are in there
came from epa guidance something called
304a guidance
so these are big documents that have
been scientifically there it's basically
accumulation of all the science about
these various different chemicals we
just had one come out on selenium for
example and it's this long multi hundred
page document that's filled with all the
science about selenium and then it goes
through a peer review process and then
goes through a public comment process
and then it actually gets approved and
the states use that to set criteria
that's the only way
that we have ever set criteria for
surface water quality in this state is
by using those those those kinds of
guidance documents epa is working on
that right now on this issue of bafs
we expect to see some drafts of that in
2023 so not that long from now we expect
to see that epa will have accumulated
the science and begun this process of
vetting public review and adopting these
kinds of guidance criteria so we think
that it's prudent
to not spend the resources now
um because those guys those guidance are
going to come out anyway
and understand what they say before we
would be diving into how we would want
to apply them within our own waters
the only other thing that i'll just say
is that you may be aware and this is
obviously pfas is a big issue and we're
very serious about it at des and we want
to be driven absolutely by science
we recently did a study of lakes in the
southern part of the state in which we
identified which we actually looked at
the fish themselves
are the fish themselves safe for people
to eat
fishing and we posted advisories on five
lakes in the southern part of the state
we can do that today we have the ability
so if we find if somebody brings us a
fish
and said and we test it and they give us
the data we can run the numbers to see
if it's safe to eat
we think that that's a much better
approach today to be able to deal with
this issue of how pfast is ending up in
fish than to try to develop a water
quality standard for it because we
currently have that and already we're
doing it
as we showed we already did five lakes
the scary thing about this
and this is the part that kind of freaks
me out i'll be honest with you
is that when we measured the water in
those lakes
that had fish that were not safe to eat
the pfas levels were undetectable
this i think highlights the very tricky
issue related to this bill
is how would we go about setting those
numbers
when we're not even sure how this stuff
is getting into the fish
i'm going to close there see if you have
any questions about this and leave it
for other people to uh to talk about
thank you very much for your time thank
you for your testimony any questions
representative cohen
thank you for taking my question
are there uh do you have access to other
states that are trying to do the same
thing with fish consumption numbers or
is this a brand new science that nobody
in the united states has attempted yet
it's a great question representative
cohen thank you very much i appreciate
that the answer is absolutely lots of
states are working on this
simultaneously and that's why there's
the states are putting so much pressure
on epa
to come up with sort of the the the gold
standard of of data and research because
otherwise we're going to end up with
again a patchwork of regulation
where we have waters that flow from one
state into another state
and we um have
and we're all sort of out there babes in
the woods on our own new jersey is
certainly attacking this issue
people point to texas texas set
screening levels that are
extraordinarily high like thousands of
parts per trillion that we're not
they're not even relevant to the numbers
that that we see in the and the effects
that we see here so
um there certainly are states that are
working on this and this is why again
the states are putting a lot of pressure
on epa right now to do this science
thank you for explaining that to me
absolutely thank you
thank you representative
okay uh horseshoe pond was one of those
points that were on the thing yes sir so
but
that one was non-detect too
i thought hey we have a little bit of i
just wanted to make sure horseshoe pond
because i know it's one
one fish per child per day
yeah we we did we did not detect it
there and if we did it was in the like
one part per trillion or something like
that it was very very low okay now
bioaccumulation a lot of people probably
haven't even heard that thing how long
does
pfest stay in the in the in in the
system of a human and or a fish
yeah i don't know the answer to that um
the the interesting thing
again this this this this whole topic is
really fascinating from a scientific
perspective um
the pfas compounds that we detected in
the water
were not the pfas
compounds that we detected in the fish
and we're not entirely sure whether
that's a bioaccumulation issue whether
that those compounds are changing as
they go through the food chain and
because most almost the only thing you
ever find in fish or p is p foss
so even if you have p4 or p5s you know
or pffs whatever you know all the other
ones
even if you find those you tend not to
find them in the fish
so it's a really
challenging question
and it depends on the chemical because
some of these chemicals sit in different
parts of the fish so this is a very
different issue than say with mercury
which sits in one part of the fish
whereas pea fast sits in other parts of
the fish and so when we look at it from
a toxicological perspective you thinking
about what parts of fish do people
actually eat
for example we have a lot we have a uh
we have an advisory on on lobster tamale
for pcbs because we know that that's
where the pcbs actually accumulate is in
the lobster tamale which is nasty and no
one should eat it anyway
but
be that as it may
be that as it may um
it's a difficult question to answer yeah
thank you representative smith thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
dears for taking my question which is
more a clarification i was madly trying
to take notes while you spoke and you
have told us in the past and you told us
again today that rules are in review and
in a few months we'll have something to
look at or somewhat you know it'll be
it'll be happening
and
my understanding was that the rules had
to do with amounts of pfas compounds
in surface water is that correct
yeah so this again this this gets back
to the very confusing aspects of
of surface water quality criteria which
are have right there's nine different
criteria that can apply to any water
body it's not like a drinking water
criteria which has there's a number it's
drinking water
this this has nine different ways that
we can look at it so the mcls well i'll
try to make this as clear as i possibly
can
when we adopt the mcls the drinking
water mcl's that were already developed
for the four compounds for which they
were developed
when we adopt those they will apply to
surface waters within 20 miles upstream
of a drinking water intake
so they will only apply to those waters
they won't apply to any other waters in
the state except for those which are 20
miles upstream
of a drinking water intake
but it will be the number in the surface
water will be
that mcl
for
again the purposes of drinking water so
it does it provides sort of a belt and
suspenders approach
to
drinking water protection because it's
already and this is one of the things we
talked about last time is that the
drinking water system is already
regulated
by these mcls right you can't have more
than this so if it's in your surface
water
at levels that are higher than that you
still can't serve it up to people
because they're testing and they have to
make sure that they're so they're
already going to be cleaning that water
before it goes out to drinking water
systems so that's that's the implication
of this is that it is really truly a
belt and suspenders approach to drinking
water protection
thank you does that answer the question
i'm sorry yeah well because the notes i
had were mcl's apply only to drinking
water so this explains you're saying
that if the surface waters are
uh
if if there's drinking water
downstream
20 miles
then those mcls would apply yes okay
right exactly precisely
yep
thank you
i have any other questions for mr dears
seeing none thank you mr deus for your
testimony thank you all if you have
questions afterwards please don't
hesitate to email me or call me thank
you very much
my last pink card in opposition mr boyd
smith mr smith
hey good afternoon
vice chairman and committee thank you
for
taking the time to
to review the testimony that we've
submitted and to allow me to few minutes
to speak my name is boyd smith i'm the
president and ceo of the new hampshire
water works association
and we represent the public drinking
water utilities and providers in the
state of new hampshire
um
again you've got more technical
information that i can't build on
anything that mr deer's provided he's
clearly an expert in the field
i should say anecdotally it's pleasure
to work with ds and partnership on
clean water issues
so there's just a couple things i wanted
to touch on i want to reinforce
i think what i said last week and i'll
say next week if the opportunity is
required
is that the drinking water industry is a
we see ourselves as
health providers really
uh our job is to create a
product that you can safely consume
every day for your entire life and you
know not get sick so uh
the people that work in this industry uh
take it very seriously it's it's an
honor to serve with them um they're
really mission driven and that's the
mission clean water
um we have to use regulations like we're
talking about today we have to use
standards we've got to come up with
numbers to treat towards
for the for this system
you have to know what you're treating
too to develop the treatment processes
and the monitoring processes
and for all the various standards
that
that are put into law there's a lot of
work behind them
i mean as you heard from mr dears
assessing the
standard for drinking water is is one
you throw surface water and you've got
nine it just gets exponentially
complicated
um i i've worked in has waste
investigations and and cleanup for
probably better part of 20 years a
little bit in the past but i i literally
swam in these waters
my point being is the process for
determining
standards is really important because
there's a lot of rides on it you know
our health rides on it there are cost
implications uh huge cost implications
which most people by the way aren't
aware of and understandably so
and there's technology as well sometimes
we don't have the technology to treat
what's bad for us and that's a tough one
but i want to reassure you that people
that work in this industry
are professionals and they take you know
the treatment of
their drinking water incredibly
seriously so this is a surface water
standard you might wonder why i'm here
for you know for a drinking water uh
organization but the majority uh the
biggest systems uh pull water uh their
source water out of out of surface water
and the merrimack's a big one uh nashua
pentachuck is gets their
source water manchester's adding seven
million gallons a day out of
uh the merrimack um concord surface
water rochester portsmouth dovers and
mix
surface water is the principal source
for our largest population centers
i know i'm rambling a little bit but i
think what i want to close on that
particular point is
we need to use the established processes
these risk risk processes
risk-based health-based
feasibility-based processes that the des
is using that the epa is using to create
a
science
justifiable feasible health standards
and my understanding is that related to
this bill that's currently underway
so i'd say let those processes work you
know watch the processes support those
processes if there's a need
or the sense of urgency
i would say support the processes that
have been established for decades now to
set these uh health-based risk-based
standards
more anecdotally anecdotally i would say
i think i understand the pressure that
we're all under and perhaps you more as
representatives uh to do something you
know this pifa stuff in particular is
it's like a bomb you know it's just it
blew off in our backyard it's been
around us for years most people didn't
know it and now you know in large part
thanks to d yes we're finding it all
over the place i think ted said they've
got 6 000 wells they've tested and they
do more every year
it's really scary stuff and we want to
do something you know we want to attack
this problem
uh
communicating to um my neighbors you
know my friends your constituents that
this stuff takes time and it's
complicated is not an easy sell it's
something as an association we're trying
to figure out how to do
but it has to be done because we can't
just jump at
whatever numbers are flying around
before they're established because there
are long term and substantial
ramifications and that's one of the
messages i wanted to bring to you today
and one of the reasons that as an
association we oppose the bill
we've got to use that process and if
there's anything that we can do as an
association one of the things we focus
on is trying to help consumers of water
understand these things is that going to
solve the issue of you know of pfas
whose numbers are getting lower and
lower as far as the threat goes no it
isn't it's not an easy problem
but um
hopefully we can work together to
you know communicate how this process
works and give our people safe water to
drink now and for years to come
um
i think the uh you know you have my
testimony uh our testimony and i i think
it mirrors a lot of what mr deers told
us without that level of detail
but i think
i think that's really all i wanted to
say today i hope this is helpful to you
if you have any questions i'd be happy
to take them if i can't answer them now
i'll get back to you as soon as i can
thank you for your service and thank you
for the opportunity to speak to you
thank you any questions for mr smith
i don't see any
thank you for your testimony thank you
sir is there anyone else that wishes to
speak on house bill 1440 i don't have
any more pink cards
not seeing anyone approach the mic i'll
call this hearing closed
captioning not available
you